Then multiply the result by the average out of court settlement, C. If X is less than the cost of a recall, we don't do one. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nr. 67. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einem neuen Durchgang durch das Chaosradio Express Universum, der Ort, wo ihr alles erfahrt, was ihr noch niemals wissen wolltet. Wir haben den 17. Januar 2008 und ich behalte die hohe Frequenz, die hohe Sendefrequenz bei, in der hier Podcasts rausgestrahlt werden. Und jetzt bin ich gerade unterwegs. Und zwar bin ich heute angekommen in Köln, sitze hier in den Räumen des Chaos Computer Club Cologne, kurz auch C4 genannt. Und ja, mit mir ist FD0. Hallo FD0.
Hallo Rest.
Hallo Rest. FD0 sitzt hier, weil er jemand ist, der sehr kundig Auskunft geben kann über ein Thema, das mir schon seit längerem am Herzen liegt, nämlich Mikrocontroller. Kleine Prozessoren, die ein bisschen mehr haben als nur das eigentliche Herz einer CPU. Und was man damit machen kann, das wollen wir hier mal ein bisschen ausloten. Ja, wir haben ja auch allerlei, ihr hört es schon, ihr tweetet hier irgendwie, das ist mein Stuhl, das ist hier der besondere Running Gag dieser Sendung.
Ja, wir haben ja so uralt Stühle im Club stehen.
Ja, aber dafür habt ihr viele, das ist ja besser als gar nichts.
Die tweeten aber alle, also bis auf diese zwei Neuen, aber einer von denen quietscht auch schon.
Ebay, oder?
Nee, irgendwo Reste, Büroauflösung oder sowas, ja.
Irgendwo Reste, irgendwo mal reingerannt, alles rausgerissen.
Genau, so ungefähr.
Ja, trotz alledem eine nette Umgebung. Der C4 ist auch extrem kabelsalatig, wenn man sich hier so her schaut.
Also man muss sich das vorstellen, so ein Kellerraum mit an der Decke aufputzverlegten dicken Röhren und wir haben einfach die Röhren benutzt, um die Kabel festzutackern und haben noch so große Kleiderhaken in den Ecken angebracht, wo dann die ganzen Kabelstränge so drüber geführt werden. Das sieht alles ganz lustig aus.
Brasilesk. Ja, die Räume gibt es ja hier auch schon seit einiger Zeit und sie werden auch genutzt, rege. Unter anderem gab es hier eine Veranstaltungs-Serie, die unter dem Namen U23 bekannt ist. Du hast da ja ein bisschen was mit zu tun gehabt. Kannst du mal erläutern, was da gemacht wurde?
Na ja, U23 ist eigentlich entstanden, dadurch, dass wir uns überlegt haben, oder dass sich der Cephalon und ein paar andere damals überlegt haben, als ich noch nicht dabei war, dass es eigentlich ganz cool wäre, wenn wir auch mal irgendwie so Nachwuchs bekommen würden, weil man wird ja immer alle älter und nur durch so Vorträge und irgendwie Ankündigung im Web. Das reicht normalerweise nicht. Da hat sich Cephalon maßgebend darüber Gedanken gemacht und irgendwann war dann die Idee so, ja, wir machen mal so eine Hardware-Challenge, wo wir so Schüler und Leute unter 23 einladen, im Team was zu basteln und mit einer bestimmten Fragestellung dabei, einer Aufgabe dabei und dann guckt man, was bei rumkommt. Bei diesem Projekt rumgekommen ist dann 2002 das erste U23. Es ging damals darum, also wir haben auch speziell ein paar Firmen angeschrieben und es gab dann von Lego größere Hardware-Spenden als Mindstorms, Bastelboxen und sowas und unter anderem von einer anderen Firma noch so ein Chip auf DOS-Basis mit Ethernet dran und damit sollte in drei Gruppen ein fahrbarer Roboter gebaut werden, der ja so einem schwarzen Strich folgen kann und an einem Ende dieses schwarzen Striches einen Barcode lesen soll und anhand dieses Barcodes irgendwelche Sachen machen soll. Da ist natürlich alles nicht fertig geworden und die Roboter waren so, also sie konnten halt den Strich folgen und so weiter, wie das jetzt im Ende ausgelegt hat.
Wie lange ist da entwickelt worden?
Das war an sechs oder acht Abenden plus ein Wochenende.
Also einmal die Woche sozusagen.
Ja genau, immer so Donnerstagsabends, dann hier in den Klubräumen bzw. damals auch in der FH, glaube ich, plus ein Hackerwochenende in Schloss Heiligenhofen bei Wermelskirchen da hinten. Das ist auch eine sehr chillige Umgebung. Es gibt da vor allen Dingen kein Netz.
Hacker Royale.
Genau, es ist mitten in der Pampa und es hat so ein bisschen Pfadfinder-Style, aber richtig schick, also mit gemeinsam kochen und irgendwie die Küche wieder sauber machen. Aber es war immer sehr chillig. Ich habe das immer sehr genossen. Das war 2002. Da gab es, glaube ich, 25 oder 30 Leute, die daran beteiligt waren. Und ich war nur, weil C-Fallon mich damals auf dem Easter-Hack in Düsseldorf ausgebuddelt hat, wo ich das erste Mal so auf so einer Chaos-Veranstaltung war. Deswegen war ich auf Schloss Heiligenhofen auch dabei. Und das war eine sehr chillige Umgebung, weil man halt, die Leute haben dann natürlich nach so einem Tag oder so war dann die Schlafrhythmen völlig durcheinander und es war dann so 24 Stunden, war dann irgendwas los.
Wie viel haben denn daran teilgenommen?
An dem U23.
Ja, an dem U23.
Also 25 bis 30 Leute.
25 bis 30, das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge.
Genau, und dann sind halt noch Leute vom C4 auch mit nach Heiligenhofen gefahren.
Und die waren wirklich alle unter 23?
Ich glaube schon, beim ersten Mal auf jeden Fall, ja.
Aber ihr habt euch nicht die Personalausweise zeigen lassen.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Es geht eher so um das gefühlte Alter.
Ach so, na dann hätte ich ja auch noch mitmachen können.
Naja, wenn du möchtest. Also die Target-Group war so Schüler und Azubis. Und wenn dieser Azubi jetzt halt 24 ist, dann ist er halt 24. Das ist meine Güte. Wir hatten bei dem U23 2005, wo wir das von Nordlicht gebaut haben, da war auch jemand da, der war 30. Na gut, fühlt sich halt unter 23 und sah auch nicht so aus. Von daher hat mir das auch nachher erst erzählt. Aber von daher ist das auch nicht so wild. Aber es geht wirklich.
Aber es hat an sich schon funktioniert. Also es war bewusst jetzt mal an junge Leute unter 23 gerichtet. Und das greift auch. Mit anderen Worten, wenn man mal ruft, dann kommen sie auch. Man muss halt nur mal ein bisschen Arsch hochkriegen, oder?
Ja, man muss auch ein bisschen Social-Enginieren. Man muss zum Beispiel jemanden kennen, der für Heise schreibt, dass man da eine Meldung reinkriegt, weil durch Heise haben wir so ungefähr den größten Zulauf gekriegt. Wir haben versucht, Plakate aufzuhängen in Schulen und so weiter, aber das ist ein riesen Problem. Ich bin den ganzen Tag mal mit jemand anders noch durch Aachen gelaufen, hab versucht, in Aachen Plakate aufzuhängen in Schulen. Aber die Schulen sind da sehr, sehr vorsichtig geworden, weil die wissen ja nicht, was das für ein Verein ist. Und dann geht man immer ins Sekretariat und erklärt das und sagt, man ist hier irgendwie gemeinnütziger Verein und macht ein Jugendprojekt, ob sie nicht das Plakat aufhängen können. Und dann sagt die Sekretärin, ja, ich leg's meinem Rektor vor und dann passiert gar nichts. Die sind halt immer ein bisschen vorsichtig, was ich auch verstehen kann, weil wenn da irgendwelche Eltern Leute dahinschicken...
Aber sind jetzt Plakate wirklich nötig?
Nein, nein, also wir haben auch... Mittlerweile greift das doch im Netz, oder? Ja, im Netz schon, aber des U23, wir haben auch kaum... Also ich weiß keinen einzigen, den wirklich durch so ein Plakat zu uns gekommen ist. Das ist alles nur, die das bei uns auf der Seite gelesen haben und dann natürlich heise, klar. Jeder junge Computerhacker liest heise.
Naja, ich mein, es gibt schlechtere Quellen.
Ja, das ist wohl wahr, aber ach, ich frag mich manchmal, ob das Missmeldungen sein müssen, aber na gut.
Ja, man muss nicht mit allem einverstanden sein, aber ich glaub, mit der grundsätzlichen Linie kann man schon noch zufrieden sein. Wie auch immer, das ist ja nicht unser Thema, wir wollen hier nicht auf Medienkritik und ich wollt jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so viel darüber reden, aber ich fand das Projekt insofern sehr bemerkenswert, weil es halt einfach einerseits sich bewusst an junge Leute gerichtet hat, aber andererseits auch und vor allem, weil es sich eben bewusst an Hardware-Entwicklung gerichtet hat. Das war also nicht so ein, naja, jetzt kommt da mal vorbei und dann surfen wir zusammen.
Naja, wobei das, das war beim ersten Mal 2002 war es halt ein Hardware-Projekt und in der Regel ist das so, dass es immer alterniert. Also 2003 war es ein Software-Projekt.
Was habt ihr da gemacht?
Da haben wir mit, auch wieder mit Leuten unter 23, das ganze Voraussetzungen waren genauso, aber wir haben ein Programm gebaut, was ICMP-Pakete benutzt, um zu chatten. Also, dass man über ICMP-Pakete, also so normale PING-Pakete, man kennt das ja, so ein Echo-Request und Echo-Response kommt da zurück, das ist das PING- und das Pong-Paket und die haben hinten Daten dran. Normalerweise ist das irgendwelche wirren Daten, dann guckt man nur, ob man die zurückkriegt, die man hingeschickt hat. Da kann man aber beliebige Daten reinpacken. Und da haben wir dann einfach gesagt, okay, ja, dann schreibt ihr jetzt hier mal ein Programm mit einem spezifisierten Protokoll, was hinten dran an diese PING-Pakete noch irgendwelche Chat-Messages hängt. Im Privates-Ware kann man das auch noch ausbauen mit Encryption und allem, was man so haben will. Und das war auch ganz erfolgreich.
Aber ihr seid dann wieder auf Hardware zurückgekommen?
Ja, genau. 2004 war kein Projekt. Da hat sich irgendwie niemand bereitgefunden, das zu organisieren. Also 2002 und 2003 hat Cephalon das organisiert. 2004 war nicht. 2005 habe ich das dann in die Hand genommen. Anfang des Jahres 2005 war irgendwie die Idee, bebasteln irgendwas mit Mikrocontrollern. Da war dann jemand aus dem Club, der hat das gerade entdeckt. Da hatten wir hier auch niemanden, der sich mit so was beschäftigt hat zu der Zeit. Dann ist derjenige aber auch nicht in eine Pötte gekommen. Dann lagen halt diese Steckbretter, die wir gekauft hatten, diese Atmels, die wir gekauft hatten, die lagen da rum. Dann habe ich mir die genommen und habe damit gespielt. Da bin ich überhaupt dazu gekommen. Da habe ich dann das Fnordlicht gebaut. Das ist so ein Moodlight, wenn man so will. Da kann man gleich noch was darüber erzählen. Das haben wir dann 2005 gebaut mit den Leuten. Das war auch sehr erfolgreich. Da hatten wir 40 Teilnehmer sogar. Wir hatten uns vorher nicht überlegt, dass das so einen Run gibt. Wir hatten vorher nicht überlegt, wie wir das mit der Auswahlprozedur machen. Da hatten wir einfach keine Auswahlprozedur, wenn es zu viele Leute gibt. Da haben wir einfach alle genommen. Das war sehr voll hier. Unsere Räumlichkeiten waren so voll, dass sie sich dann auch aus Martekisten Tische gebaut haben, um drauf zu löten. Das war so voll, dass man hier auch nicht mehr durchgehen konnte.
Fnordlicht, das ist dieser kleine Elektronikbaumkuchen, den ich gerade in der Hand halte.
Baumkuchen ist gut.
Naja, so drei übereinander gesteckte Platinen. Ganz oben ist eine Matrix, kann man gar nicht richtig dazu sagen.
Das ist eine Anordnung, fast hexagonal, aber nicht ganz.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall viele bunte LEDs. Das sind auch bunte LEDs, oder?
Ja, das sind rote, grüne und blaue. Also jeweils einfarbige, aber davon dann rot, grün und blau.
Um, wie du so schön sagtest, Mood zu machen, also eine Atmo-Lichtsteuerung sozusagen. Und was steckt jetzt drin hier in diesem Teil?
Da steckt ein Atmega-8 drin. Das ist ein Atmel-Mikro-Controller aus der Architekturserie AVR. 8-Bit und der macht die Lampen an und aus.
Das heißt, der Stein, der da drauf ist, dieser eine Chip, und das ist ja im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur dieser eine, da sind noch ein paar Bausteine drauf, aber das sind halt eher die notwendigen kleinen Widerstände, Kondensatoren usw., die man immer so braucht aus Deko-Zwecken.
Ja genau, das ist alles auch völlig nicht intelligent.
So, und mittendrin steckt halt dieser Mikro-Controller.
Was ist? Hühnerfutter nennt sich das übrigens, wenn man so drumherum noch das ganze Getüdel da.
Hühnerfutter? Ah, den Begriff kennt ich noch gar nicht. Ich bin auch echt kein Hardware-Guy. Also frag ich mal ganz doof, was ist ein Mikro-Controller?
Ein Mikro-Controller ist eine Verbindung aus zwei Dingen. Und zwar einmal einen Prozessor, der da drin steckt und der ganzen Speicher- und Peripherie-Ansteuerung, die drumherum ist. Also beispielsweise einfach so eine CPU selber nutzt mir halt nicht viel. Man kennt das ja von einem Rechner, wenn man eine CPU hat. Eine CPU alleine sieht zwar schick aus, aber macht gar nichts. Die möchte dann wenigstens noch irgendwie ein Mainboard drumherum haben. Und wo dann so drauf ist so eine Ansteuerung, dass da Takt reinkommt, dass man mit der Außenwelt kommunizieren kann, dass die CPU ihre internen Register, also Speicherbänke, die sie da hat, dass die auch irgendwas nach draußen kommunizieren können, da braucht man halt so ein bisschen Peripherie. Und das ist in einem Mikrocontroller, alles in einem Chip komplett drin. Da ist also Speicher drin, wo ich mein Programm reinflaschen kann, also permanenter Speicher. Da ist ein bisschen RAM drin. Da ist ein bisschen EPROM-Speicher drin, wo ich Konfigurationszeug ablegen kann. Und da sind ganz viele Eingabe-Ausgabe-Pins, wo ich zum Beispiel LEDs dran hängen kann. Da ist ein serieller Port mit drauf, das ganze Zeug, was man so braucht.
Das heißt, im Prinzip ist es ein kleiner PC. Bloß halt nicht nach PC-Spezifikation, sondern halt ein Computer. Ein kleiner Computer, aber vollständig mit Speicher, mit Ein- und Ausgabekanälen. Aber der Takt wird schon noch von außen hier eingeführt, oder? Der Quarz liegt nach wie vor daneben.
Genau, da ist ein Quarz-Oscillator drauf, der 16 MHz macht. Aus dem ganz einfachen Grund, weil ich das damals als erstes probiert hab und das gut funktioniert hat. Heute würde ich da keinen Quarz-Oscillator mehr nehmen, sondern nur noch einen Quarz, weil der ungefähr ein Fünftel davon nur kostet. Der Unterschied ist einfach, dass der Quarz-Oscillator, der gibt so ein Rechtecksignal raus und der Quarz, der braucht noch ein bisschen Ansteuerung, damit der los schwingt. Aber der Atmel hat auch eine interne Taktquelle, die standardmäßig auch aktiviert ist, mit einem Megahertz. Die kann man aber maximal nur bis 8 Megahertz hochfahren. Ein anderer Nachteil ist, dass das kein Quarz ist, der also sehr genau schwingt, sondern es ist einfach nur ein RC-Schwingkreis und der ist z.B. Temperatur- und Spannungsabhängig. Das heißt, so serielle Kommunikation, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt, dass ich einen ordentlichen Takt habe, kann man damit nicht so toll machen.
Aber verstehe, wenn er warm wird, dann verliert er sein Timing ein bisschen. Wird er ein bisschen zu schnell oder ein bisschen zu langsam?
Man kann das zwar nachführen, aber das ist auch alles nicht so schön und deshalb nimmt man bei so timing-kritischen Sachen oder wenn man halt über 8 Megahertz hinaus will, dann nimmt man halt einfach eine externe Tagquelle.
Und sonst ist hier nicht viel drauf, außer dem Hühnerfutter?
Ja, es ist eigentlich noch viel zu viel drauf. Da das meine erste Schaltung war, die ich so gebaut hab, ist da noch viel zu viel Zeug mit drauf.
Was kostet so ein Steinchen?
Der Atmel selber, den kriegste für 1,70 Euro bei Reichel zum Beispiel. Und da ist schon recht viel dabei. Also man kann im Prinzip mit so einem Steckbrett und einem Atmel und ein paar LEDs und irgendwie so ein Programmierkabel kann man halt loslegen. Das kriegt man alles zusammen für unter 10 Euro.
Mit anderen Worten, ein Microcontroller ist einerseits einfach zu verbauen. Man muss nicht sehr viel Elektronikkenntnisse haben, fast eigentlich kaum welche.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Daumenregeln, die kriegt man ziemlich schnell mit und dann geht das.
Zumindest jetzt, man muss nicht in der Lage sein, irgendwie groß irgendwas zu designen und mehrere komplexe Systeme zusammenzuschalten, sondern man muss ein bisschen mal das Verstanden haben mit dem IO. Port und so weiter und wo man hier noch irgendwie das Hühnerfutter drauf verteilen muss, aber das geht. Und dann kann man im Prinzip programmieren und sich ein System bauen, was einerseits klein ist, andererseits wahrscheinlich relativ wenig Strom frisst.
Ja, richtig.
Also unter Umständen dann auch mal mit Batterien lange läuft.
Der Atmel, wenn man den in den entsprechenden Power-Down-Modus schaltet, weil der ja normalerweise, also der ist ziemlich effizient und normalerweise hat er nichts zu tun in der Regel, dann eidet der durch so eine Schleife durch, dann schaltet man ihn in den Power-Down-Modus und dann verbraucht der unter 1 mA. Also das ist fast nichts.
Und dann geht's los und dann kann man Dinge schalten und dann kann man Lampen an- und ausmachen und dann kann man, ja, was weiß ich, alles Mögliche machen und vor allem kann man diese Dinger ja auch gut kombinieren mit Sensoren aller Art. Was weiß ich, Temperatursensoren, Infrarot-Sensoren und so, was man halt aus der Robotik jetzt auch schon kennt. Und eigentlich stecken solche Systeme ja heutzutage nahezu in jedem halbwegs intelligenten Small-Size-Gerät mit drin. Ja, das ist fürchterlich.
Teilweise selbst in Taschenlampen und so, wenn man da verschiedene Blinkmodi hat, habe ich letztens gesehen, fand ich ganz schick. Wobei da, also bei dem Fnordlicht muss man sagen, das ist jetzt explizit auch darauf ausgelegt, dass es einfach zu löten ist. Also auch für Lödanfänger habe ich darauf geachtet. Deswegen sind das alles noch in dieser uralten Monster-Riesigbau-Form. Diese Taschenlampen, Mikrocontroller, die dann so in Consumer-Elektronik drin sind, so ganz einfache Consumer-Elektronik, die sind in der Regel unter so einem, ja, 5 Millimeter durchmessenden Plastiktröpfchen verborgen. Da ist die gesamte Elektronik außenrum und der Mikrocontroller sitzt einfach unter diesem Tröpfchen. Man kommt nicht dran, kann nicht gucken, gar nichts.
Wobei man natürlich auch gut geschützt ist.
Ja, das ist richtig. Auch durch Auslesen von Konkurrenten und sowas.
So, genau. Und darum soll es eigentlich gehen, mal so ein bisschen rauszukriegen, was das eigentlich bedeutet, jetzt mit Mikrocontrollern zu arbeiten, weil man damit eben einfach coole Hardware bauen kann. Also wenn man schon immer mal die Idee hatte, irgendwas in Bewegung zu kriegen, was aber so ein bisschen den eigenen Befehlen gehorchen soll, dann ist das so der richtige Ansatz. Das haben wir ja schon erwähnt hier, auf dem Teil ist ein Atmel-Chip drauf. Atmel ist ja eine Firma und diese CPU-Systeme, die sie herstellen, die sind ja extrem populär. Ich glaube, diese Atmel-Dinger...
Ja, die sind sehr, sehr weit verbreitet, ja...
.sind einfach mit Abstand der Marktführer, oder?
Weiß ich nicht so genau. Also es gibt bei Mikrocontrollern zumindest diese Low-End 8-Bit-Mikrocontroller... Genau, was gibt es denn alles? Es gibt so eigentlich zwei Firmen, die sich da so den Markt so ein bisschen aufteilen, habe ich den Eindruck. Das ist zum einen Atmel mit diesen AVRs, die sind auch sehr günstig.
Also AVR ist der Name für diese Prozessorfamilie.
Genau, das ist der Architekturname. AVR sind 8-Bit-Mikrocontroller mit Speichergrößen. Ich glaube, die gibt es mittlerweile bis 256 Kilobyte Flash für Programme und irgendwie 4 oder 8 Kilobyte Arbeitsspeicher. Klingt wenig, kann man aber ganz schön viel mitreißen. Und das andere Firma ist Microchip mit den PIC-Mikrocontrollern. Die sind ein bisschen mehr, was so Hardware angeht, die da auf dem Mikrochip, auf dem Mikrocontroller noch mit drauf ist. Beispielsweise haben die welche, da ist gleich ein Ethernet-Chip mit integriert oder ein USB oder sowas. Das hat Atmel irgendwie nicht. Aber die unterscheiden sich auch sehr signifikant in der freien Software, die es dafür gibt. Also mir war es damals auch wichtig, ich habe irgendwie keine Lust. Und das ist bei vielen Mikrocontrollern so, dass man da erst ein Windows booten muss mit irgendeiner komischen Entwicklungsclick GUI. Was schick ist, das gibt es von Atmel auch, das sogenannte AVR-Studio. Aber das ist halt alles so Windows bloat, wer will ich nicht? Dann muss ich noch wieder einen neuen Editor lernen, um mich irgendwie in der IDE zurechtzufinden. Und da muss man sagen, das hat Atmel eigentlich sehr schick gemacht. Es gibt nämlich den GCC für AVRs. Und Atmel unterstützt das auch aktiv. Das heißt, die arbeiten da teilweise dran mit oder geben zumindest alle Dokumentationen so frei. Also das ist auch sehr schick. Man kann einfach auf die Seite gehen, kann sich da für die Prozessoren die Datenblätter runterladen und kann auch die komplette Architekturdefinition, welche Opcodes gibt es, wie lange dauern die, kann man alles runterladen, gibt es da alles und man braucht sich irgendwie nicht mal registrieren dafür. Das ist total super. Und mittlerweile setzt auch dieses AVR Studio, also diese kommerzielle GUI von Atmel, die man aber auch so runterladen kann, wenn man das möchte, die setzen auch GCC ein. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schick. Und Microchip, da gibt es nicht mal einen Compiler für Linux oder für irgendwelche anderen freien Betriebssysteme. Das ist fürchterlich. Da gibt es unter Windows diese GUI-IDI-Click-Dingsbumms und die macht das. Das höchste der Gefühle ist so ein Programmierprogramm, mit dem man so ein Programm auf so einen Microcontroller flashen kann. Das gibt es wohl, aber viel mehr auch nicht. Deswegen hat mich das von Anfang an abgeschreckt und ich habe da aber auch nicht wirklich mehr reingeguckt. Also es kann sein, dass meine Infos nicht mehr ganz aktuell sind.
Das heißt, so ein Teil, jetzt haben wir es ja schon erwähnt, GCC, programmiert man dann in C?
Das kann man tun, ja. Man kann das aber auch, wie ich das gemacht habe, in Assembler programmieren. Das ist auch durchaus noch gängig. Und teilweise muss man das auch, wenn das...
Also Assembler heißt, dass man einfach direkt den Codeset, den der Prozessor selber anbietet, direkt so nutzt, ohne dass irgendwas übersetzt wird.
Genau, die CPU da drin versteht ja Befehle. Das sind, ich glaube, 64 Stück oder so. Und diese Befehle kann man natürlich auch direkt schreiben. Da ist dann auch so ein bisschen Magic drum herum, dass man halt nicht alle Sprungadressen absolut exakt berechnen muss, sondern dass man da so ein Label dranpappt und dann berechnet der Compiler die Sprungadresse. Und wenn man dann vorne mal so eine Instruktion einfügt, muss man nicht alles selber machen, das macht halt der Compiler schon. Also man hat auch für den Assembler dann so einen Compiler, da gibt es irgendwie fertige von Atmel oder auch eine ganze Menge freie Projekte. Und wenn man, gerade wenn man timing-kritische Sachen programmiert, dann muss man in Assembler programmieren.
Erklär doch mal ein bisschen, wie diese Assembler-Programmierung aussieht. Ich erinnere mich jetzt bei ganz vielen Podcasts, kam immer wieder so zur Sprache, naja, damals früher, Klondike, als wir noch alle Assembler programmiert haben und so. Ich meine, ich habe das auch gemacht. Damals in 80er Jahren war das halt einfach en vogue und notwendig. Da gab es keine Compiler, so auf so einem Commodore 64. Klar, da konnte man natürlich Basic machen. Das ist ganz schön für 10-Print-Halo-20-Goto-10. Aber wenn man da halt mal ein fetziges Spiel oder eine coole Animation oder was weiß ich machen wollte.
Oder wenn man auf den Rand malen wollte, das ging nämlich auch nur in Assembler.
Genau, man kam einfach nicht drumherum, eine gewisse Systemnähe zu suchen. Mit der Zeit in den 90er Jahren, wo die Rechner einfach so wahnsinnig schnell geworden sind, denken natürlich die meisten nachvollziehbarerweise nicht im Traum daran, auf diese Ebene wieder runterzugehen, weil man natürlich mit einer Hochsprache ganz andere Abstraktion machen kann. Nur hier reden wir ja nun wirklich über Signal von Da-Empfang und daraufhin Da-Lampe einschalten. Das heißt, am Ende ist das, was das System tut, immer nur so dieses, ich beziehe mich auf irgendwelche Daten oder Ereignisse und danach schalte ich irgendwas von 0 auf 1 oder von 1 auf 0. Also es sind ja so keine komplexen Vorgänge. Genau. Wie sieht denn jetzt diese Maschinensprach-Ebene aus? Also was für eine Abstraktions-Ebene muss man sich da einlassen, um so ein Ding zu programmieren?
Also erstmal muss ich sagen, ich bin eigentlich niemand. Ich hab nicht mit Assembler-Code angefangen. Ich hab damals mit Basic angefangen und bin dann sehr schnell zu Delphi unter Windows übergewechselt. Ich hab also vorher nie Assembler programmiert. Also gar nicht. Ich bin damit jetzt erst angefangen. Das fand ich sehr schick. Es ist auch aktuell so, ich hab mir jetzt gerade letzte Woche wieder einen Code angeguckt. Da hat jemand eine richtig coole Sache geschrieben für so ein Ad-Mail-AVR. Und zwar ein USB-Stack in Software. Der macht das komplette USB alles in Software. Und da kommt es wirklich auf jeden einzelnen CPU-Zyklus an. Und das hat er natürlich in Assembler geschrieben. Und das ist eine unglaubliche Leistung, dieses Teil. Weil ein Bit USB bedeutet acht Prozessorzyklen. Und diese acht Prozessorzyklen muss ich das Bit vorher verarbeiten und mich auf das Neue vorbereiten.
Bei wieviel Megahertz?
12 Megahertz. Also das sind jetzt 16. Es gibt dann auch einen für 16. Der hat ein bisschen mehr Zeit. Und ich bin gerade dabei, diesen Stack auf 20 Megahertz zu portieren. Aber das ist schon sehr, sehr abgefahren und richtig, richtig schick. Die Abstraktionsebene, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, naja, was so eine CPU hat in der Regel Register. Normalerweise, wenn man heute Leute fragt, was ist ein Register, dann können die meisten sich da nicht wirklich was drunter vorstellen. Jetzt aktuell so einen Informatik-Studenten fragst, vielleicht aber irgendwie so ein Fachinformatiker, der das irgendwie gelernt hat, irgendwie zumindest zu programmieren, er wird in der Regel nicht wissen, was ein Register ist. Genauso wenig, muss ich selber sagen, wusste ich auch nicht, was ist ein Interrupt? Was ist das wirklich? Was passiert da? Ich wusste irgendwie unter DOS, da gab es so Hardware, die brauchte Interrupts und die musste man dem irgendwie geben, sonst tat das nicht. Aber viel mehr wusste ich nicht. Und wenn man sich so eine CPU anschaut, dann hat diese CPU in der Regel so Außenkommunikation, also der CPU-Kern, so irgendeinen Adress- und Datenbus, und in der Regel hat diese CPU mehrere Register. Das sind einfach so Speicherbänke innerhalb der CPU. Wenn man sich das jetzt vorstellt, was die CPU für Befehle akzeptieren könnte, dann gibt es zum Beispiel auf dem Atmel jetzt einen Befehl namens LDI, der in ein Register irgendeinen konstanten Wert, beispielsweise 23 lädt. Das ist alles. Wenn ich jetzt mit diesem Wert in dem Register irgendwas machen will, dann gibt es da zum Beispiel einen anderen Befehl, der einen Wert aus einem Register nimmt und dann irgendeine Speicherstelle des Arbeitsspeichers schreibt. Darauf muss man sich dann einlassen. Also LDI R16,23 lädt die 23 in das Register R16. Dann gibt es irgendwie STM. Das ist der Befehl, um einen Registerinhalt in den Arbeitsspeicher zu schreiben. Dann sagt man halt, okay, hier STM Z, das ist ein Pointer-Register, R16. Und dann schreibt er den Wert, der in R16 steht, irgendwo in den Speicher.
Also man sitzt da als Mikrocontroller, wie so ein achtaumiger Buddha, da in seinem Sandkasten und legt im Prinzip die ganze Zeit mit seinem Schäufelchen irgendwelche Bomben von A nach B.
Und das ist auch fürchterlich. Man kommt sich ja teilweise vor wie Türme von Hanover. Man muss erst irgendwie den Wert in ein Register, von dem Register in ein anderes Register, und von dem Register dann irgendwo anders wieder hin. Das ist so fürchterlich. Aber es ist total super, weil man sehr, sehr deterministisch genau weiß, was die CPU gerade tut. Weil das steht in der Spezifikation drin. Da steht halt drin dieser LDI-Wert. Der ist in einem Prozessorzyklus fertig. Und wenn das da drin steht, dann ist das auch so. Und dann kann ich da wirklich mit rechnen. Also wenn ich jetzt weiß, ich lade diesen Wert halt dreimal, dann brauche ich drei Prozessorzyklen. Bei 16 MHz Takt bedeutet das ein durch 16 Millionenste mal drei. Dann bin ich fertig. Und damit kann ich unglaublich genau auch Takten machen. Das ist total super.
Ja, also das ist wirklich hardware-nahe Programmierung. Dazu kommt halt dann noch das Interapp-Management. Ich weiß nicht, so eine Admin-CPU, was für Interapp-Möglichkeiten hat die?
Na die hat zum Beispiel Interapps, wenn man jetzt so die in dem Mikrocontroller eingebaute Peripherie nimmt, beispielsweise serielle Schnittstelle. Die hat einen Interapp, da ist ein Datenbyte angekommen.
Das heißt der Interapp, das muss man vielleicht nochmal erläutern, heißt einfach, was auch immer gerade läuft, wird unterbrochen, wird eben interrupted. Und das Programm setzt in dem Moment seinen Fortgang an einer anderen vorher definierten Stelle fort, wo man gesagt hat, wenn das und das passiert, dann bitte hier. So, dann muss auf diesen Interapp reagiert werden. Und wenn der dann sozusagen ausreichend bearbeitet ist, Datenpaket wurde empfangen, irgendwelche Bedingungen sind beendet, dann sagt man, okay prima, alles. Und dann läuft es wieder da weiter, wo es eben unterbrochen wurde.
Genau, man muss sich das natürlich so vorstellen, dass auf dieser CPU läuft ein einziges Programm, da gibt es kein Betriebssystem. Das heißt, wenn ich Hardware brauche, muss ich sie selber initialisieren und ich muss sie selber benutzen. Und ich muss mir im Zweifelsfall auch so Sachen wie zum Beispiel, was man so aus C kennt, dynamische Speicherallokierungen mit malloc oder so was, das gibt es da einfach nicht. Da gibt es zwar eine libc, die sogenannte AVR-libc, die solche Funktionen bereitstellt, aber das ist dann schon C. Und das hat wirklich jemand dafür implementiert. So, und wenn ich jetzt in meinem Programm, was da gerade läuft, mein Programm ist dadurch definiert, dass es da ein Register namens PC gibt, Program Counter, das ist ein Zeiger, der zeigt immer auf die aktuelle Instruktion. Und im Prinzip nach der Instruktion wird der von der CPU eins weitergesetzt und dann geht's da weiter. Und wenn mein Programm gerade läuft und es kommt ein Interrupt, dann merkt die CPU, ah, ich muss was tun, speichert diesen Program Counter Wert auf dem Speicher zwischen und nimmt sich den Interrupt her. Das ist in der Regel am Anfang des Programms, also an der Adresse 0123 und so weiter, vom Flash, also wo mein Programm drin liegt, da gibt es Sprungadressen in die einzelnen Interrupts. Und da stellen sich aber auch schon ganz interessante Fragen, die man so, wenn man in der Hochsprache programmiert, ist man vielleicht mal drüber gestolpert, wenn man so einen Interrupt dann bekommt, beispielsweise wenn man so eine Steuerung C abfangen will, dass sich das Programm halt ordentlich beendet, muss man irgendwie so einen Signal-Handler unter Linux installieren. Dann kriegt man halt teilweise schon mal mit, dass das irgendwas Besonderes ist, weil so Variablenwerte, die ich im Hauptprogramm überprüfe und die in meinem Signal-Handler geändert werden, die werden vom Hauptprogramm eventuell gar nicht erkannt. Eben weil das Hauptprogramm sieht, ah guck mal hier, meine Sachen werden gar nicht verändert, das heißt ich muss die nicht aus dem Speicher irgendwo laden, sondern ich kann die aus meinen Registern nehmen. Und solche Sachen stellen sich natürlich bei Interrupt-Handling auf eine Mikro-Controller auch. Ich muss mir ganz, ganz bewusst sein, welche Variablenwerte wo wann verändert werden. Wenn ich beispielsweise eine Variable habe im Hauptprogramm, 16 Bit lang, dann besteht die aus zwei Bytes. Und der Admin ist eine 8-Bit-Architektur, das heißt ich werde diese zwei Bytes einzeln bearbeiten. Was aber passiert, wenn mein Hauptprogramm das erste Byte geladen hat, dann ein Interrupt kommt, wo das Hauptprogramm nichts von merkt, der die beiden Bytes verändert und erst dann lädt mein Hauptprogramm das zweite Byte? Dann hat das einen völlig konfusen Wert eventuell und da muss ich dann schon echt fies drauf achten. Mittlerweile ist das schon so ein bisschen besser. Ich hab damals, als ich damit angefangen hab, komplettes Blackbox-Debugging gemacht, weil es gibt zwar einen Simulator, aber das ist dann, also für diese Admin gibt es einen Simulator, aber das ist diese Windows-Click-Gui. Die ist ziemlich gut und die habe ich auch mal benutzt, um da mein Timing zu überprüfen, weil da kann man dann so gucken, von hier nach da, wie viele Prozessorzyklen hast du denn gebraucht, aber eigentlich ist das ein bisschen Blackbox-Debugging gewesen. Wenn man größere Mikrocontroller nimmt, die hat dann eine sogenannte JTAG-Schnittstelle. Das ist so eine Standard-Debug- und Programmierschnittstelle.
Die ist mit einem Mikrocontroller mit drin?
Genau, die ist auch mit drin.
Das sind einfach noch ein paar Pins von dem Chipsintervall, für geopfert.
Wie viele sind das? Ich glaube, vier oder fünf mit Reset. TDI, TDO, TDMS, TDCK und ja, fünf sind es, glaube ich. Das ist aber in diesem kleinen Atmega 8 noch nicht eingebaut. Der Atmega 16 hat dann 40 Pins, der hat das schon eingebaut. Da gibt es auch noch eine Schnittstelle, die nennt sich DebugWire. Das ist so was ganz komisch-proprietäres von Atmel. Da weiß ich gar nicht, wie das läuft. Und so JTAG-Adapter, das ist mittlerweile Standard. Ich musste da jetzt im Studium auch ein bisschen, also ich studiere Informatik in Aachen, ich musste da auch im Studium jetzt ein bisschen was mitmachen. Das ist eigentlich schon ganz schick. Also man hat da diese Windows-Clicky-Buntigui mit dem JTAG-Adapter und kann dann halt auch so Breakpoints setzen und kann dann in der CPU, also live auf der Hardware debuggen. Das ist schon ganz schick. Das hätte ich mir damals ehrlich gesagt auch gewünscht. Aber das habe ich jetzt mittlerweile ja auch, weil ich bin jetzt auf eine Architektur höher eingestiegen mit ARM 7 und da gibt es das halt auch. Und das ist eigentlich auch total cool, weil Atmel stellt nicht nur diese kleinen AVRs her, sondern auch ARM 7-Prozessoren, auch ARM 9 und auch da drüber. Und da kann man dann wirklich mit GDB unter Linux, mit dem Standard-JTAG-Adapter, mit GDB seinen C-Code, den Assembler-Code, auf dem ARM 7 live debuggen. Das ist schon sehr schick.
Ja, jetzt wollen wir doch noch mal ein bisschen im Matsch bleiben. Und vielleicht auch mal hier bei diesem Fnordlicht bleiben. Beschreib doch noch mal kurz, was das Fnordlicht eigentlich genau tut.
Das Fnordlicht ist eigentlich aus der Idee entstanden, dass ich mein Apartment im Studentenwohnheim leuchten wollte, aber halt so Standardzeug hatte ich halt durch, so Deckenfluter und Schwarzlichtröhren. Das wird irgendwann alles langweilig. Da habe ich mir dann überlegt, es wäre eigentlich schon verdammt cool, das steuern zu können. Ich muss allerdings zu meiner Schande gestehen, dass ich meine Fnordlichter, die da immer noch im Schrank liegen, noch nicht eingebaut habe. Die sind aufgelötet und getestet und gebaut. Ja doch, ich habe also zwei Fnordlichter hinter meinen Monitoren stehen, aber ich habe auch schon so Metallringe an die Wand geschraubt, wo ich so einen Blumentopf reinstecke, weil das war so ein 8 cm Tonblumentopf, das Gehäuse, was ich mir für die Fnordlichter ausgedacht hatte, weil der ist einfach super billig und den kriegt man überall. Die sind einfach noch nicht da reingesteckt und die Verkabelung ist noch nicht gemacht. Das muss ich unbedingt noch machen.
Was würden diese Geräte tun, wenn du sie in Betrieb genommen hättest?
Diese Geräte würden Licht machen. Es war eigentlich rein rechnerisch 16 Millionen Farben, also verschiedene, immer eine gleichzeitig. Aber realistisch schafft man das nicht, weil man die Farben ja eh nicht unterscheiden kann. Ich kann jeden dieser drei Farbkanäle, Rot, Grün, Blau, kann ich 255 verschiedene Helligkeiten.
Wie viele Lampen sind das hier?
27 insgesamt, also 9 mal 3 Farben. Genau, 9 von jeder Farbe.
Gut, aber das ist ja eigentlich egal. Man steuert ja alle gleichzeitig dann sozusagen in neuner Gruppe an. Das heißt, im Prinzip hat man hier einmal Rot, einmal Grün, einmal Blau. Und so eine LED geht halt immer an. Das heißt, wenn ich sage, du hast jetzt Strom, dann ist das Ding an. Und wenn ich sage, du hast keinen Strom, dann ist es aus. Und wenn man es dimmen will, das heißt, wenn man unterschiedliche Helligkeiten erzeugen will, dann ist man ja gezwungen, über einen bestimmten Zeitraum die Lampe halt so und so häufig an- und wieder ausgeschaltet zu haben.
Es gibt da zwei Möglichkeiten, das zu machen. Das eine ist PWM, das eine ist PFM. Das PWM ist die Pulsbreitenmodulation oder Pulse Width Modulation. Und das andere, das ist eigentlich das Gebräuchlichere. Und das andere, das hat zum Beispiel der Steini an seinem... Also die Gruppe um den Steini hat so einen RGB-Farbwürfel gebaut, vorletztes Jahr auf dem Kongress. Genau, und die machen PFM, das ist Pulsfrequenzmodulation. Da ändere ich nicht die Einschaltdauer der LEDs, sondern ändere ich die Anzahl, wie oft sie eingeschaltet werden. Und bei Pulsbreitenmodulation überlege ich mir, dass ich die LEDs einfach länger anlasse, wenn sie heller sein sollen.
Das hab ich auch mal so gemacht, über so ein Blinkenlight-Teil. Das funktioniert aber eigentlich ganz gut, oder?
Ja, das tut auch ziemlich gut. Das ist auch bei LEDs, die haben den Nachteil, LEDs klingeln Tims Handy, das ist gut.
Das ist nur wieder so eine Mitteilung, dass ich jetzt gleich einen Podcast aufnehme.
Das ist ja praktisch. Das hat meine Freundin auch mal gemacht. Sie hat sich das Handy eingetragen, weil sie Urlaub hat.
Immerhin ist es über UMTS drin und stört hier nicht unsere Aufnahme. Okay, aber lass dich nicht unterbrechen von meiner LED-Hardware.
Pulsbreitenmodulation ist schon ganz cool, weil man LEDs eigentlich nicht so gut über Strom oder Spannung dimmen kann. Zumal das LEDs waren, die ich da verwendet hab, das waren billig China-Krams und die sind sehr unterschiedlich. Also so eine LED hat immer so eine Spannung, bei der sie am liebsten leuchten möchte. Und diese Spannung selber, die ist halt einfach bei verschiedenen LEDs sehr unterschiedlich. Also die Herstellungsbreite ist da, da gibt es so ein Auseinanderdriften von den Seiten.
Na gut, aber das Funktionsprinzip ist jetzt eigentlich relativ klar. Wenn ich Farbe X herstellen möchte, muss ich halt die entsprechende Rot-Grün-Blau-Mischung Genau, wie man das von Webseiten kennt. Genau, wie das jeder Computer macht. Da wird dann halt auch der jeweilige R, G oder B-Pixel mehr oder weniger hell angestrahlt.
Genau, richtig.
Und hier muss man halt die Helligkeit quasi in Zeit umsetzen. Das heißt, man betrachtet dann, was weiß ich, eine Sekunde und sagt, in dieser Sekunde muss ich halt die Lampe 50 Prozent der Zeit anhaben, wenn sie halt 50 Prozent hell sein soll.
Ja, so in der Art. Das ist der naive Ansatz.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt da noch die Kiste mit der Gammakorrektur. Da gibt es das Problem, dass das Auge etwas anders reagiert, als man das erwartet. Das ist das, was man als Gammakorrektur bei Monitoren auch kennt. Das Problem ist nämlich, dass das Auge gepulstes Licht heller wahrnimmt, als es eigentlich ist. Deswegen reicht das für 55 Prozent der Helligkeit, reicht schon 25 Prozent der Zeit an sein. Das muss man ein bisschen korrigieren. Das ist sehr unschön, weil man bei den niedrigen Helligkeiten sehr enge Zeitschlitze kriegt.
Das ist sehr unschick. Die Beobachtung hatte ich auch seinerzeit gemacht. Aber vom Prinzip her. Man muss das über die Zeit verteilen. Jetzt hat man eine Anforderung. Das ist es. Das ist das, was das Snortlicht tut. Es macht nichts anderes als im Output. Das Programm, das auf diesem Mikrocontroller läuft, soll über die Zeit immer eine vorgegebene Farbe erstellen und muss die richtigen Lampen zum richtigen Zeitpunkt an- und ausschalten. An der Stelle muss man die entsprechende Software schreiben. Hier kommen dann wieder unsere Interrupts ins Spiel. Erzähl doch mal, wie diese Software funktioniert. Was macht der Code?
Diese Software hat zwei Bestandteile. Zum einen eine Hauptschleife. Die ist dafür zuständig, weil der Prozessor langweilt sich die meiste Zeit. Deswegen habe ich Farbskripte implementiert, die ablaufen können. Man kann Farbverläufe einprogrammieren, dann geht der Farbverlauf durch. Jetzt mal ganz einfach bleiben. Wir wollen diese LEDs dimmen, und zwar auf drei Kanälen, nämlich die roten, die grünen und die blauen. Dafür müssen wir PWM machen, das ist der naive Ansatz, der funktioniert auch gut, da gibt es auch die Software dafür. Das Problem ist, wenn man das 50% der Zeit anmacht, wenn man das auf so eine Sekunde betrachtet, dann leuchtet die LED eine halbe Sekunde, und es ist eine halbe Sekunde aus. Das ist blöd, weil das ist ein ziemliches Geflimmer. Deswegen habe ich kleinere Zeitschlitze genommen, das kam rechnerisch ziemlich gut hin, und habe gesagt, wir arbeiten mit einer Frequenz von 120 Hertz, das heißt, ich betrachte nicht einmal eine Sekunde, sondern eine 120-Tel-Sekunde.
Warum ausgerechnet 120-Tel?
Weil bei 16 MHz, also ich mache mein Timing mit Hilfe einer eingebauten Hardware, eines sogenannten Timers, da kann ich sagen, hier, zähl mal so schnell, und bei einem eingestellten Wert, der als Höchstgrenze fungiert, gib mir bitte einen Interakt.
Also in der Hardware im Micro-Control?
Genau, in der Hardware im Micro-Controller.
Das heißt, der Micro-Controller selber besitzt die Möglichkeit, dass man eben sagt, in so und so viel Zeit, oder so und so viel, alle regelmäßig, oder wie läuft das?
Ja, kann man, gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Einstellmöglichkeiten.
Genau, also alle möglichen Arten und Weisen gibt es ihm zu sagen, dass nach Ablauf einer bestimmten Zeit ein Interakt erzeugt wird.
Genau, richtig.
Einer von mehreren unterschiedlichen Interakten.
Genau, und der AVR ATMEGA8 hat jetzt zum Beispiel drei von diesen Timern. Zwei Stück können nur bis 255 zählen. Hier haben wir so ein 8-Bit-Register, wo ich sagen kann, hier zählt bis 120 oder so. Das ist aber bei 16 MHz ist das nicht so viel. Also man kann es im Timer dann auch noch sagen.
Aber was zählt denn der dann?
Der zählt Systemtakte oder Systemtakte durch 8 oder durch Systemtakte durch 64 und so weiter. Da gibt es also sogenannte Pre-Scater.
Ah, okay, das heißt, man nimmt sozusagen Systemtakte, in diesem Fall ist die 16 MHz.
16 MHz, genau.
Und dann nimmt man sich irgendein Divisor, durch den man das teilt. Und damit kriegt man so eine gewisse Zeiteinheit. Und davon kann man dann 256 unterscheiden oder 255.
Ganz genau, richtig. Und dann habe ich mir halt überlegt, was man da, also es gibt auch einen dieser Timer, der hat halt 16 Bit, das sind halt zwei 8-Bit-Register, wo man seinen zu erreichenden Wert reinschreibt. Dann habe ich halt ein bisschen rumgerechnet und da kam das halt richtig cool hin, dass man das mit 120 Hz, das ging halt glatt auf. Das ist relativ wichtig, weil so Floating-Point-Gedünsel auf so einem Mikrocontroller macht überhaupt keinen Spaß.
Ja, und ist auch komplett unnötig.
Also ich hab halt geguckt, ich hab mit den Prescalern gespielt und hab mal ein bisschen rumgerechnet und dann kam halt raus, 120 Hz ist super. Das ist auch über 100 Hz, bei 100 Hz hat man ja früher gesagt, es sollten die Monitore dann mindestens haben als Bildwiederholrate, damit das ordentlich ist und man das flimmer nicht sieht. Beim Flottig ist es eigentlich ein bisschen wenig. Also ich hätte gerne noch mehr, da muss ich noch mal optimieren. Aber 120 Hz ist schon mal ganz cool. So, und dann gibt es jetzt diesen einen Teil in der Software, das ist diese Hauptschleife, die sagt halt, okay, ich hätte gerne bitte irgendwie 50% rot und 25% grün und 25% blau. Dann gibt es einen anderen Teil der Software, der wird vom Timer-Interrupt ausgelöst und sagt dann, oh ja, jetzt muss ich die LEDs einschalten. Dann setze ich halt die Zeit, nach der die LEDs wieder ausgeschaltet werden müssen. Dann kriege ich wieder einen Interrupt, schalte die LEDs wieder aus und dann warte ich, bis der nächste Zeitschlitz anfängt. Das mache ich eigentlich immer. Und das muss ich halt für jede Farbe machen.
Das heißt, Zeitschlitz heißt, wir haben unsere Sekunde. Diese Sekunde ist in 120 Schritte unterteilt. Und jedes Mal, wenn sozusagen wieder so eine 120. Sekunde abgelaufen ist, löst der Prozessor, der Microcontroller einen Interrupt aus. In dem Moment wird ein spezieller Code aufgerufen, die sogenannte Interrupt-Routine, die nichts anderes macht als für jede LED, die zu diesem Zeitpunkt vorgeplante und zugedachte An- oder Aus-Zustand für die LED herzustellen.
Genau, richtig.
Weil da steht irgendwie, wir wollen hier 50% Blau haben. Und eben 50% heißt, dass ich dieses An-Aus-An-Aus-Muster irgendwie haben muss. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da mit Tabellen vorher arbeitest. Ja, ich hab eine vorberechnete Tabelle, ja. Genau, du berechnest dir sozusagen ein Bitmuster, was dann eben über diese 120 Schritte verteilt werden muss oder was auch immer du da betrachtest, eine Sekunde oder wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, er weiß, was das nächste Bit ist, was sozusagen gesetzt werden soll und er reagiert einfach auf diesen Zeitinterrupt und nimmt dann sozusagen den nächsten Wert und setzt den und dann geht die Lampe an oder aus?
Wobei das wirklich, das ist nicht auf eine Sekunde betrachtet, sondern nur auf eine 120. Sekunde. Ich berechne also jede 120. Sekunde, berechne ich neu, wann ich welche LEDs anderen ausmachen muss. Weil, wenn man jetzt, also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass der gewünschte Farbwert konstant ist, also dass man den jetzt mal nicht ändert, dann ist ja jede 120. Ich muss immer in jeder 120. Sekunde 50% blau machen. Dann ist es einfach am Anfang, mache ich LEDs, die an sein sollen, mache ich an. Wenn jetzt gar kein Grün dabei ist, brauche ich die LED natürlich gar nicht erst anmachen. Aber nehmen wir jetzt mal an, ich will nur 50% blau haben, also so ein dunkles Blau. Dann mache ich am Anfang eines Zeitschlitzes die blauen LEDs an und warte einfach, bis ich sie wieder ausmachen soll, dann kriege ich wieder einen Timer-Interrupt. Das wird von der Hauptschleife richtig eingestellt und dann warte ich einfach, bis der nächste Zeitschlitt anfängt. Und in der Zwischenzeit hat der Prozessor quasi Langeweile.
Das heißt, das ist das eigentliche Engineering, also auf diese Ebene muss man es runterbrechen. Man muss sein Problem, was ja bei so einer einfachen Hardware auch irgendwie simpel zu beschreiben ist, so weit runterbrechen, dass man sagen kann, jetzt muss ich nur noch dafür sorgen, dass zum richtigen Zeitpunkt einfach die richtigen Werte an die richtigen Stellen geschrieben werden. Wie kriegt man jetzt diese LEDs an diesen Microcontroller angeschlossen?
Das war nicht ganz so einfach.
Du hast ja keine 27 Stück, du hast ja keine 27 Ports.
Nee, hab ich auch nicht. Eigentlich brauch ich ja nur drei Pins von dem Microcontroller, nämlich einen für grün, einen für rot, einen für blau, die mir sagen, jetzt diese entsprechenden LEDs bitte anmachen. Das läuft einfach so, dass diese Pins ein Rechtecksignal ausgeben. Wenn dieses Rechtecksignal 5 Volt ist, dann sollen die LEDs bitte an sein. Wenn es 0 Volt ist, sollen die aus sein. In Wirklichkeit ist das nochmal invertiert. Das hat historische Gründe, weil man früher bei Microcontrollern eine gewisse Zeitspanne zwischen der Strom geht an und der Microcontroller läuft los. Das ist heute immer noch so. Es gab dann Microcontroller, die haben ihre Ausgabe Pins immer alle auf 5 Volt gelegt. Da wollte ich verhindern, dass das funktioniert, dass man, wenn man den Strom einsteckt, so einen Riesenmonster Lichtblitz hat und erst mal nichts mehr sieht. Deswegen habe ich das invertiert gemacht. Genau so in der Art. Aber das ist nicht so wichtig eigentlich, weil das Invertieren, ja gut, das ist halt ein...
Na gut, wenn es nicht so wichtig ist, dann reiten wir auch nicht weiter drauf rum.
Genau. Ansonsten, das sind halt drei Pins, eins für rot, eins für grün, eins für blau. Die werden nach dieser Invertierungsgeschichte, schalte ich damit einen Transistor. Und dieser Transistor schalte...
Warte mal, diese Pins sind jetzt an den Microcontroller.
Genau, richtig.
Das heißt, das sind normale Ausgabeports.
Genau, richtig. Wenn man sich so einen IC vorstellt, also insgesamt, die nicht belegt sind, also in der Regel sind diese Microcontroller-Pins mindestens zweifach belegt, was man halt so damit nutzen kann oder möchte, der hat so 16, realistisch, von 28, die da an dem Gehäuse dran sind. Das sind halt ein paar Stromversorgungspins. Und einer ist zum Beispiel Reset, den man auch noch als Ausgabepin nutzen möchte, wenn man so einen Microcontroller nicht mehr programmieren muss. Dann braucht man natürlich diesen Reset-Pin auch nicht. Aber so 16. Genau so in der etwa. Ich nutze halt drei Stück davon. Und mit diesen drei Stück schalte ich Transistoren. Und diese Transistoren schalten LEDs ein oder aus. Das heißt, ich habe an dem Nordlicht, das möchte so, wenn es hoch kommt, so 14 Volt, möchte es gerne haben als Eingabe. Dann sind das so zwei Spannungsregler, die machen aus diesen 14 Volt, 12 und 5. Mit den 5 Volt wird der Microcontroller betrieben, mit den 12 Volt werden die LEDs betrieben. Muss man sich so vorstellen, LEDs sind immer drei Stück in Reihe geschaltet, also hintereinander. Oben hängen die an den 12 Volt. Und unten hängen die an einem Transistor, der sie mit Minus verbindet. Und dieser Transistor macht gleichzeitig, also der schaltet es nicht nur ein und schaltet die LEDs nicht nur ein, sondern er macht eine Stromregelung, der begrenzt den Strom, den diese LEDs ziehen dürfen, auf 21 mA. Das ist ein ganz klein bisschen über dem, was sie eigentlich haben möchten, aber sie gehen auf jeden Fall nicht kaputt. Da muss man bei LEDs immer ein bisschen aufpassen. Das ganze Zeug gibt's übrigens bei lohraster.org schrägstrich Nordlicht. Da gibt's die ganzen Schaltpläne und alles, was man da so hat. Also wer grad Netz hat, kann das ja beim Podcast hören, kann sich das ja mal angucken. Da gibt's auch gleich auf der Webseite die Schaltung und da dann mal auf, ich glaub, die Display-Platine war das, da sieht man das auch direkt. Tim hat's auch grad mal aufgemacht. Nee, nee, ich hab schon, ich mach bei uns im Bodenheim die Netzwerkadministration und da gibt's auch schon mal öfter mal Leute, die dann, wenn sie neu eingezogen sind, vor meiner Tür stehen und klopfen und dann sieht man so, die zittern dann so. Dann wollen die halt Netz haben und haben meistens noch nicht mal das Zimmer gestrichen, aber wollen erst mal Netz haben. Das ist immer ganz nett.
So, jetzt, ich wollte ja ein bisschen hier mal das ein bisschen nachvollziehen, damit man sie einfach mal in Vorstellung davon machen kann, was es eigentlich bedeutet, jetzt wirklich so ein Teil zu programmieren. Dass es nämlich auf der einen Seite ein bisschen ungewöhnlich ist, auf der anderen Seite auch so schwierig nicht, soweit meine These. Jetzt ist die andere Frage, woher weiß dieses Gerät welche Farbe denn gewünscht ist?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Also zunächst mal kann man dem Programm sagen, mache diese Farbe. Das ist quasi ein fixer Wert, den man da einmal beim Programmieren fest setzt. Dann schaltet man es ein und dann macht es blau. Das ist allerdings ziemlich langweilig, habe ich mir dann auch gedacht. Und dann habe ich mir erst mal überlegt, dass zwischen diesen Zeitschlitzen hat der Prozessor ziemlich viel Langeweile, weil der tut nichts anderes als darauf warten, dass endlich bitte dieser Timer auslöst. Also wenn man auf so einen Kuchen wartet, der im Ofen steht, irgendwann klingelt der Wecker und dann ist es endlich so weit, da muss man nochmal warten, bis er abgekühlt ist. Und da kann der Prozessor ja noch was Sinnvolles tun. Und da habe ich mir eine kleine Skriptsprache überlegt, wo man halt sagt, ok, hier, den Blaukanal, fäde den mal ganz langsam hoch. Und zwar nicht jetzt von null auf gewünschten Wert, sondern mach mal immer ganz langsam. Und da kann man dann auch recht intelligente Farbskripte draus basteln, in dem man sagt, ok, jetzt setze mal, mach mal den Blaukanal ganz langsam komplett an, wenn du damit fertig bist, dann machst du den Grünkanal wieder ganz aus. Und so kriegt man dann so einen Farbwechsel hin. Und wenn man diese drei, also in der Regel läuft da pro Farbkanal genau ein Skript. Und diese Skripte laufen halt drei Stück parallel. Und wenn man das dann so bastelt, dass die sich nicht so schnell wiederholen, dann kriegt man da auch sehr schicke Farben hin, die sich auch scheinbar nicht wirklich wiederholen. Also wenn man diese Zyklen von null bis ganz an pro Farbkanal so wählt, dass die nicht gleichzeitig immer fertig sind, dann kriegt man da auch schon mal hin, dass das eine halbe Stunde lang immer verschiedene Farben macht, die ganze Zeit. Also meine Mutter hat so ein Ding im Wohnzimmer stehen, was ich immer zu Weihnachten geschenkt habe und ist da immer ganz froh geworden.
Aber von außen steuern kann man es jetzt nicht?
Doch, kann man. Und zwar hat der Mikrocontroller, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, eine serielle Schnittstelle. Und da kann man dann, also man muss da noch einen kleinen Konverter davor schalten, der die normalen seriellen Signale von minus bis plus zwölf Volt mikrocontroller-kompatibel macht, sogenannter Pegel-Konverter. Und dann kann man auch mit dem Fnordlicht reden und kann ihm sagen, hier, mach mal diese Farbe. Aber das fand ich auch ein bisschen blöd, weil ich will ja nicht immer bei meiner Zimmerbeleuchtung den Rechner daneben stehen haben, dann tut er nicht, dann muss man den booten und wenn ich den mal neu installiere, das ist alles blöd. Also jemand von dem U23, der das wieder da 2005 mitgemacht hat, hatte eine ganz coole Idee. Und zwar gibt es eine Möglichkeit und eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit, Infrarot- Fernbedienungssignale zu dekodieren. Da gibt es ein fertiges kleines Bauteil, was auch irgendwie 60 Cent kostet oder so. Und das gibt direkt demoduliert die Fernbedienungssignale da raus.
Also das Bauteil ist im Prinzip ein Infrarot-Empfänger.
Genau, das ist ein Infrarot-Empfänger und sogar mehr als das, weil da hat noch ganz viele Filter mit drin, sodass man da gar keine Streusignale kriegt, sondern nur wirklich so Fernbedienungssignale. Und da können wir auch später nochmal drauf gehen. Genau, vom normalen Fernseher. Oder so, wenn man jetzt irgendwie an den Grabbeltisch geht, dann kriegt man auch für 2 Euro so eine Universalfernbedienung und sucht sich irgendeinen Code raus. Damals haben wir RC5 implementiert. Das ist so ein Philips-Code. Und dann kann man mit einer Fernbedienung seine Beleuchtung steuern. Und das fand ich schon sehr schick. Da hat Patrick damals angefangen, das zu implementieren. Da hat er dann irgendwie gerade keine Zeit gehabt. Dann hab ich das komplett mal fix fertig gemacht noch. Und das geht natürlich auch sehr einfach. Hab ich leider auf dem Hardware-Design des von Nordlichts nicht vorgesehen, weil ich einfach damals noch nicht wusste, dass sowas geht. Aber man kann mit 3 kleinen Kabeln und diesem externen IC, nennt sich ein TSOP, ist das zum Beispiel, TSOP 1738, wenn man was zum googeln braucht. Ist das ein Bauteilsymbol? Das ist ein Bauteilsymbol, das heißt so eine 1738. 17 ist die etwas genauere Typenbezeichnung und 38 bedeutet, der reagiert auf 38 Kilohertz gepulstes Infrarotlicht. Und damit kann man sehr einfach Sachen steuern, beispielsweise andere Skripte auslösen oder Sachen umschalten oder das an- und ausmachen und alles, was man so will. Ich hab da eingebaut einen RC5-Infrarot-Decoder, da bekommt man, wenn ein Infrarot-Code decodiert wurde, ein Signal und kann dann sagen, das war die Taste 5 und Taste 5 heißt, mach mal grün. Das funktioniert auch ziemlich gut.
Und diese Universal-Bedienung kostet nicht viel, haben viele Tasten.
Genau, richtig.
Und dann kann man alle möglichen Programme abrufen und man kann sich das ja vor allem auch selbst so programmieren, wie man möchte.
Genau. Erst war noch die Idee, dass man die Nordlichter untereinander, wenn man mehrere davon hat, auch vernetzt, über das I2C-Protokoll. Das ist ein 3-Draht-Bus, der eigentlich dafür gedacht ist, dass ICs auf einer Platine sich unterhalten. Das hab ich ausprobiert. Da gibt es auch ein Video, was der Cephalon damals gedreht hat, wo ich ein bisschen, also da hat jemand anders noch ein XMMS-Plugin geschrieben, um Nordlichter anzusteuern. Aber das hat nicht so gut funktioniert, weil dieser Bus ist nur gedacht für so Leitungslängen bis, weiß nicht, 10 cm oder sowas. Und wenn man da längere Leitungen dran macht, dann geht das fürchterlich in die Hose. Das war nicht wirklich was. Also ich hab zum Kongress, zum 23C3, hatte ich eine größere Nordlichtinstallation unten, also in diesem Catering-Bereich in der Mitte vom BCC, was man per Ethernet ansteuern konnte. Da hab ich ja mittlerweile noch so ein anderes Projekt, das Etherrape, da können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal drauf eingehen, was einen 8-Bit AVR Mikrocontroller mit Ethernet verbindet und einem echten TCP IP-Stack. Und der hat Nordlichter angesteuert über noch einen anderen Bus, über einen RS485-Bus. Aber dafür braucht man noch einen relativ teuren Treiberbaustein und das war alles nicht so toll. Deswegen, Infrarot ist schon super. Und ich hab mittlerweile auch mehr mit Infrarot gemacht, da kommen wir auch gleich noch zu. Da gibt es jetzt so ein anderes Projekt noch von mir, das Ansepp, und da mach ich noch mehr mit Infrarot. Infrarot ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Dieser RS485-Bus, das ist ja so ein Multi-Point-Bus, wo man so schön mehrere Dinge miteinander verdiensten kann.
Mit zwei, drei, vier Drahten.
Also für so eine billige Verstrippung von Geräten müssen ja nicht immer Lampen sein. Man kann ja jetzt mal beliebig weiter denken. Es gibt alle möglichen Sensoren. Man kann auf Lärm reagieren, man kann auf Licht reagieren. Also wenn schon Licht da ist, dann so weiter. So kann man sich halt schön mit so einer ganz einfachen Elektronik und vor allem mit so einem ganz einfachen Herz, eben diesem Mikro-Controller, eigentlich immer so das schöne Traumgerät bauen, was man gerade haben möchte. Und interessant finde ich halt dann diese Busse eben zur Kommunikation, weil man dann eben auch über so einen größeren Bereich hinweg, also was weiß ich, Heimautomation, jeder denkt sofort jetzt an seine Wohnung zurecht. Dafür war es ja auch gedacht. Genau, dafür war es ja auch gedacht und das finde ich einen schönen Antrieb. Ich finde es ganz gut, dass wir das jetzt mal so ein bisschen in epischer Breite mal durchgegangen sind, weil ich denke, es dürfte ganz gut klar geworden sein, wie man dann sozusagen vom Wunsch zum Ziel kommt und wie man so einen Microcontroller dann eben auch bedienen muss. Und die Programmierung ist, weiß nicht, wie groß ist dieses Programm?
Also die Fnordlicht-Firmware mit allen Optionen, die es gibt, also mit diesem Infrarot-Decoder und dem seriellen Ansteuermodul und ein paar Farbskripten sind so 4,5 Kilobyte von 8, die der hätte.
Also 4500 Bytes.
Also ich kann es auch gerade nochmal kompilen.
Jeder, der schon mal einen längeren Text geschrieben hat, hat wahrscheinlich mehr Bytes produziert. Und das finde ich immer wieder so erstaunlich. Heutzutage ist jeder so gewohnt, immer solche 128 Megabyte großen Installationsarchive auf seine Platte zu werfen oder noch größer, dann klickt man irgendwie so ein Programm an, dann lädt es 20 Sekunden auf so dem neuesten Gerät, was man so hat, mit Supercore, Duo, Schnick Schnack, hast nicht gesehen, rechts unten Modell. Und es dauert immer noch alles irgendwie ewig. Aber so eine ganz einfache Funktionalität kriegt man einfach mit so dermaßen wenig Code hin.
Ja, das ist aber jetzt auch schon...
Also du hast gesagt, 8 Kilobyte hat das Teil?
Genau, aber jetzt, also diese 4 Kilobyte sind genau 4,3 Kilobyte, das ist schon die C-Firmware. Und diese C-Firmware hat schon einiges an Overhead. Ich habe am Anfang eine in Assembler geschrieben, die ist noch kleiner. Also auch mit Farbskripten und allem. Und Infrarot-Decoder und überhaupt, aber die ist noch...
Ja klar, und die reine Kern-Funktionalität, so dieses Ich erzeuge eine Farbe, das ist wahrscheinlich ein paar Hundert Zeilen, oder?
Ja, es wird so ein Kilobyte oder anderthalb oder so sein. Maximal. Da ist auch echt nicht viel zu tun. Also wenn man sich, wenn man diese ganze eingebettete Hardware, die da schon mit drin ist, alle nutzt, so wie zum Beispiel ein Timer, dann kann man sich diesen Zähler-Loop sparen und so. Das ist schon sehr effizient.
Vielleicht jetzt nochmal, bevor wir nochmal auf die anderen Projekte eingehen, die ich auch ganz interessant finde, nochmal so zur Architektur der Microcontroller. Also was ja jetzt schon klar geworden ist, da ist halt ein Prozessor drin, da ist RAM drin, und zwar sowohl das RAM zum, also was man halt zur Hauptspeicher sozusagen, oder das, was man braucht, wenn das Ding läuft, als auch Flashspeicher, der also seinen Speicher auch nach dem Ausschalten hält. Also dort wirft man dann das eigentliche Festprogramm rein. Mit dem restlichen RAM wird dann eben gearbeitet.
Unterschied zu den normalen CPUs ist auch normal im Sinne von was man so kennt, zu Hause hat. Das ist auch ganz unterschiedlich. Das Programm läuft direkt aus dem Flash. Das heißt, das ist fest da drin und der Prozessor lädt jede einzelne Instruktion aus dem Flash und führt sie aus. Das heißt, man kann in diesem Flash nur sehr umständlich Daten ablegen, die das Programm generiert. Deswegen gibt es da nochmal extra das EPROM, wo man dann Konfigurationen oder Sachen, die man abgespeichert hat, ablegt.
Flash lässt sich schon schreiben, aber nur von außen, oder was?
Ja, da kann man so einen Bootloader drauf tun. Das ist aber alles ein bisschen obskur und nicht dafür gedacht, dass man Konfigurationssachen ablegt. Also Flash ist ein Speicher, den man einmal programmiert und dann ist er in der Regel konstant. Der hat auch eigentlich eine endliche Lebensdauer. Ich habe aber realistisch noch keinen kaputt gekriegt. Also er ist, glaube ich, auf 10.000 Schreibzyklen spezifiziert. Und EPROM ist dafür gedacht, das ist der Speicher, wo das Programm Daten ablegen kann. Da hat dieser Prozessor jetzt 512 Byte davon. Da könnte ich zum Beispiel Farbskripte ablegen, die das Programm selber ändern kann und so was. Der hat irgendwie 100.000 Schreibzyklen. Also schon eine ganze Ecke mehr. Und der RAM ist halt der flüchtige Speicher, wo ich so...
Das heißt, da muss man immer einen exquisiten Löschvorgang vornehmen.
Ja, aber das macht der Controller schon intern. Ich kann ihm einfach sagen, schreib EPROM, mach mal. Das ist auch ein, eigentlich ist es ein EEPROM. Das ist ein elektrisch löschbares...
EEPROMs, das war das, wo man früher den Chip rausbauen musste.
Genau, mit so einem Ultraviolettlicht löschen und so was. Aber das muss man nicht mehr da.
Okay, was hatte ich vergessen? Genau, das Ding hat Interrupts.
Ja, eine ganze Menge sogar, über 20.
Also, unterschiedliche Arten von...
Ja, genau, unterschiedliche Arten von Interrupts.
Was ist denn sonst noch außer Zeit?
Naja, zunächst mal jeder dieser drei Timer, die da drin sind, hat mindestens zwei Interrupts. Der eine sogar drei. Weil Zählerwert erreicht oder Overflow ist aufgetreten. Dann gibt es noch so einen Input-Capture-Interrupt. Dann gibt es da Pins, da kann man sich einen Interrupt geben lassen. Man kann, wenn man sehr genau Zeiten messen möchte, lässt man diesen Zähler einfach laufen, der läuft dann durch, der zählt dann von null bis 255 und fängt wieder vorne an. Und wenn man irgendein Gerät, da hat zum Beispiel so eine Lichtschranke, die sehr genau Zeiten messen soll, bis so ein 100-Meter-Läufer da irgendwie ankommt, da möchte man dann genau wissen, wann diese Lichtschranke gesagt hat, da ist jetzt jemand dazwischen. Dann in der Regel wechselt da ein Signalpegel von null auf fünf Volt oder so was. Und da kann man dann von der Hardware mitschreiben lassen, wie der Zählerstand war, und zwar genau an dem Zeitpunkt, an dem diese Flanke aufgetreten ist, dieser Wechsel stattfand. Dann kann man halt sagen, okay, hier mein Zählerstand war so und so, und dann kann man sich auch einen Interrupt vergeben lassen. Was es noch gibt an Interrupts sind so Sachen wie, da hat sich an einem Signal-Pin ein Level geändert, also beispielsweise gibt es da zwei externe Interrupts, so heißen die, wo ich zum Beispiel einen Infrarot-Decoder dranhänge, da kriege ich einen Interrupt, wenn der Infrarot-Decoder seinen Ausgangspegel ändert von 0 auf 5 oder 5 auf 0.
Also sprich, wenn man was empfangen hat.
Wenn man was empfangen hat, genau. Da ist ja empfangen tut ja erst mal nur das dekodierte Ding, aber wenn da auf jeden Fall irgendwas passiert, das benutzt man in der Regel auch, wenn man so Taster an dem Teil dran hat und der Prozessor ist im Power-Down-Sleep-Modus, dann können diese externen Interrupts dazu führen, dass man ihn wieder aufweckt aus seinem Schlaf. Da wird alles abgeschaltet, bis auf die Elektronik, die für diesen externen Taster zuständig ist. Dann gibt es noch so Sachen wie I2C, da ist da als Booster drauf vorhanden. Da gibt es so Sachen, dass man sich einen Interrupt geben lässt, wenn an die eingestellte I2C-Adresse ein Paket geschickt wurde oder ein Byte geschickt wurde oder ganz viel anderes Zeug noch.
Also das I2C, das hast du ja vorhin schon ausgeführt, das nutzt man vor allem um andere Chips, die Dinge eigenständig tun. Was gibt es da? USB-Steinchen wahrscheinlich?
USB gibt es, USB gibt es, ISDN weiß ich nicht, aber USB gibt es. Dann gibt es vor allen Dingen ganz viel noch mal EPROMs, also noch mal Konfigurationsspeicher, die man per I2C ansteuert. Dann gibt es beispielsweise TDA7318, das ist ein Audiomixer-Baustein, den man per I2C ansteuert, wo man so vier Stereokanäle die Lautstärke regeln kann. Das ist so ein typischer Autoradio-Baustein, also man um vier Stereoreien sucht einen aus, kann die Lautstärke, Höhen, Bässe regeln und gibt dann auch zweimal Stereo für vorne und hinten aus. Und da gibt es noch ganz viel anderes Zeug per I2C. Also das Problem bei I2C ist, dass es irgendwie, ich glaube, von Philips entwickelt wurde.
Siemens, glaube ich.
Siemens? Ich weiß nicht so genau. Jedenfalls wurde es entwickelt von einer Firma und die haben irgendwie ein Problem damit, wenn man es I2C nennt. Also heißt es bei Atmel immer TWI, TK, Two-Wire-Interface, weil I2C ist ein Markendingstar. Also aber alles kompatibel, also es war auch kein Problem.
Nee, du hast recht, es ist von Philips.
Du hast gerade Wikipedia nachgeschlagen, ja?
Natürlich, die heilwissende Millhandel hilft immer.
Also was es an Interact gibt, es gibt es halt für seriell, also RS232, da ist ein Datenbyte angekommen, da wurde ein Datenbyte verschickt, oder das Temporärregister ist wieder leer, ich kann jetzt das nächste verschicken. Dann gibt es noch für das EEPROM selber, das eingebaute EEPROM, da gibt es hier Schreibvorgang, erfolgreich abgeschlossen, Interrupts, und das war es im Großen und Ganzen.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Interrupts sind das, mit dem man überhaupt auf die Außenwelt reagieren kann.
Muss man nicht, das ist das Wichtige. Interrupts sind eine Möglichkeit, um asynchron, also völlig egal, was das Hauptprogramm gerade tut, auf die Außenwelt zu reagieren. Man kann auch komplett ohne Interrupts auskommen, weil jede dieser Peripherie, die ich eben aufgezählt habe, z.B. die Timer oder die seriöle Schnittstelle, die haben ganz normale Register, auf die ich mit ganz normalen Befehlen zugreifen kann. Und das Einzige, was den Zugriff unterscheidet von Interrupt versus ganz normal abfragen, also immer wenn sich da was tut, dann wird ein Bit gesetzt in irgendeinem Register von dieser Hardware. Dieses Bit kann ich entweder pollen, ich kann also immer das Register lesen, gucken, ist das Bit gesetzt? Nö, mach ich was anderes. Ist das Bit jetzt gesetzt? Nö, mach ich wieder was anderes. Oder ich kann sagen, hier, sobald dieses Bit gesetzt wird, soll bitte die CPU eine andere Routine ausführen. Das ist der Unterschied. Ich muss das nicht interappbasiert machen.
Aber es ist schon eine empfehlenswerte Vorgehensweise, weil in dem Moment, wo man auf zwei Dinge gleichzeitig warten muss und zeitkritisch ist, dann will man natürlich so schnell wie möglich davon noch kein besser halten.
Ja, das ist eine der schwierigen Sachen. Welche Sachen soll ich interappbasieren machen? Welche mache ich irgendwie lieber gepollt? Kommt ganz drauf an, was man macht. Also beispielsweise diese Geschichte mit dem LEDs an- und ausmachen, das ist ziemlich zeitkritisch. Das wird man auf jeden Fall mit Interapps machen, weil dann ist die CPU einfach besser da drin, irgendwie Sachen zum richtigen Zeitpunkt auszupacken.
Aber Datenübertragung jetzt über Schnittstellen, würde ich auch in diesem Bereich sehen.
Ja, Datenübertragung ist auch wieder so was, weil zum Beispiel rausgehendes, also wenn ich per seriell Sachen verschicke, dann ist mir das ziemlich egal, wie schnell die rausgehen. Dann sag ich einfach hier, verschick das mal, dann warte ich bis fertig ist und dann mach ich das nächste. Aber zum Beispiel wenn ich vom PC Datenbytes kriege über seriell, dann muss ich da ja natürlich so schnell darauf reagieren, dass ich das Datenbyte wegschaufel, bevor das nächste kommt. Und da würde ich dann schon zum Beispiel Interrupts benutzen. Muss man auch nicht, aber ist natürlich sinnvoll.
Okay. Aber grundsätzlich, die Software, wenn man jetzt nicht C-Compiler benutzt, arbeitet immer so mit dem Schäufelchen. Das heißt, es holt sich hier die Daten und schreibt woanders irgendwie was rein und man hat da sozusagen so ein großes Feld von Orten, wo man seine Daten auslesen und reinschreiben kann. Und das ist eigentlich der ganze Sport.
Genau, richtig.
Ja, na das ist doch fein. Nochmal so zu den Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten. Wenn jetzt jemand partout keinen Bock hat, auf die Maschinen-Sprachen-Ebene herunterzugehen, hast du ja erwähnt, gibt es für Atmel auch die Möglichkeit, mit einem C-Compiler zu arbeiten.
Genau, da gibt es mehrere. Da gibt es einen IAR, da gibt es den Keil-Compiler, das sind so Commerz-Dinger. Manchmal gibt es also Friware-Versionen, also so Shareware-Versionen, die dann ganz komisch eingeschränkt sind auf 8 Kilobyte Code-Größe maximal. Die machen da einen ziemlichen Bohi drumrum, was halt wohl ganz cool ist, dass es da so eine IDE zum Klicken drumrum gibt, die dann schon alle Controller unterstützt, die es gerade so gibt. Das ist so der Support, den man da kauft. Aber für Atmel gerade, also für Atmel AVR-CPUs gibt es auch eine sehr, sehr aktive Community rund um diesen AVR-GCC. Und Atmel selber unterstützt das, soweit ich weiß, auch. Das heißt, man hat da einen komplett fertigen, sehr gut funktionierenden Code-Compiler, unten quietschenden Stuhl. Und der Compiler ist wirklich schon sehr, sehr schön. Manchmal macht er komischen Kram, aber in der Regel macht er recht effizienten Code.
Du hast vorhin erwähnt, dass es da Probleme gibt mit der Speicherarchitektur von dem Prozessor und wie die GCC die Welt so sieht.
Ja, Probleme nicht, aber der GCC wurde eigentlich entwickelt für, ich glaube, das sind von Neumann Architekturen, wo man im Prinzip nur eine Art Speicher oder zumindest nur einen Adressraum hat. Man sagt halt hier, wie jetzt beim PC, da ist irgendwie mein Hauptspeicher, ich hab da so natürlich mit Memory Management und allem Kram, aber ich hab da so Hauptspeicher, liegt irgendwie an der einen Stelle in meinem Programm und an der anderen Stelle kann ich irgendwie Daten reinschreiben. Wenn ich versehentlich in mein Programm reinschreibe, dann ist es halt blöd, dann stürzt es ab. Das bei den AVRs ist das ganz strikt getrennt und das Problem war am Anfang so ein bisschen, dass der GCC eigentlich damit rechnet und dafür ausgelegt ist, dass es nur einen Adressraum gibt. Das Problem ist jetzt beim AVR, dass dieser Flash-Speicher eine Adressierung hat, die bei Null anfängt und das EEPROM hat eine Adressierung, die bei Null anfängt und der RAM fängt auch nochmal.
Heißt das, dass es dann für jeden Speicher einen eigenen Instruktionssatz gibt, um den dann zu adressieren?
Nee, man kann Instruktionen nur aus dem Flash ausführen. Man kann also nicht so selbst modifizierende Programme oder so schreiben, das geht einfach auf der Architektur nicht.
Ja, aber wozu braucht man unterschiedliche Adressen?
Es gibt aber auch unterschiedliche Instruktionen, um Sachen aus dem Flash zu laden, das ist ein eigener Obcode und ein Byte aus dem RAM zu laden.
Das meinte ich, es gibt eigene Befehle für den jeweiligen Bereich, die benutzen dann ihren eigenen Adressbereich, der dann aber anders ist. Okay, verstehe.
Das ist auch der Hack, den sie da gemacht haben, um dem GCC das beizubringen. Der ist so köstlich, weil diese AVRs sind eine ziemlich kleine Architektur. Es gibt also nicht so viel Speicher, deswegen kommt man in der Regel mit 16 Bit völlig aus. Mehr als 65 Kilobyte, zumindest was RAM angeht. 16 Bit als Adressierung für z.B. den RAM. Es gibt einfach 4 oder 8 Kilobyte ist gerade das Limit, was es gibt. Anderes gibt es einfach, wird nicht hergestellt. 16 Bit reicht für 65 Kilobyte. Deswegen arbeitet der GCC intern mit Adressen, die das 17. Bit auf 1 gesetzt haben. Das heißt für den AVR-GCC intern fängt der RAM halt bei 0x irgendwas an, sodass das 17. Bit eine 1 ist und der Rest 0. Und nachher wird das auf die niedrigsten zwei Byte, also auf diesen 16 Bit eingeschränkt. Tim greift sich gerade an den Kopf.
Erinnert mich an böse Zeiten damals, so Bank-Switching und so ne Sache.
Das war CCN 16?
Nee, das war, ja nicht nur, das war jedes System, was so ein bisschen an seine Speichergrenze gekommen ist. Das gab es auch beim PC, da gab es früher dieses ominöse Lim-Ram-Architektur. Hast du davon schon was gehört? Lim steht für Lotus, Intel, Microsoft. Das ist sozusagen so ein Common Agreement zwischen diesen drei Firmen, wie man der Beschränkung von 640 Kilobyte beim PC als Schnippchen schlagen kann.
Aber niemand braucht doch mehr als 640 Kilobyte.
Nein, aber das haben sie dann doch irgendwann eingesehen. Also zumindest Lotus brauchte das. Und naja, anstatt einfach den konsequenten Schritt zu gehen und auf, ich meine, das waren schon zwei 86er-Systeme, wo dann halt irgendwie ja im Prinzip viel mehr Speicher zur Verfügung stand. Nein, dann hat man dann so den RAM halt in 64 Kilobyte-Blöcken eingeblendet und das war dann halt immer eine Bank, sodass man dann eine Software brauchte, die dann immer irgendwo in einem Chip einen Bit geändert hat, um dann sozusagen aus der Reihe von Banks, die man dann hatte, das Richtige an einer Stelle einzublenden, um es dann da zu lesen und diese Art und Weise, wie das eben funktionierte, war dann halt das Lim-Memory. Und um es noch schlimmer zu machen, hat man das dann Expanded Memory genannt. Im Gegensatz zu Extended Memory. Und ich wollte schon immer mein T-Shirt machen, wo vorne Extended Memory und hinten Expanded Memory draufsteht. Wie auch immer. Du hast ja auch noch weitere Projekte gemacht.
Genau, mittlerweile ja. Das war ja 2005.
Du hast schon dieses Etherrape erwähnt. Du machst ja deine Projekte dann auch immer so mit offenen Karten.
Ich mag das total, weil ich habe sehr viel gelernt, dadurch, dass ich andere Leute Hardware-Design angeguckt habe und es rausgelesen habe. Und ich finde das super wichtig. Weil auch manche Features, die denke ich mir, die wären cool zu haben, aber ich habe jetzt gerade keine Zeit und keinen Bock, das zu implementieren. Es ist einfach schick, das freizugeben. Da hat man auch... Lizenzierungstechnisch ist das eigentlich kein Problem. Ich mache das in der Regel immer so, dass meine ganze Software ist GPL. Und das Hardware-Layout und so weiter ist in der Regel Creative Common, Non-Commercial, Share Like. Dass da jemand mit meinem Zeug, wenn er sich da hinsetzt und eine neue Platine routet, was eine ganze Menge Arbeit ist, dann kann er das gerne tun, aber bitte nicht einfach nur dumpf kopieren, das soll dann in der Regel nicht so sein. Und was ich gemacht habe nach dem Fnordlich, da kam mir irgendwann der SkyT hier aus dem C4 auf mich zu und meinte, boah, wäre ja eigentlich geil, wenn das Ethernet könnte. Da habe ich mir gedacht, so, na, Ethernet, das ist auch ganz komisch und ich hatte da schon ziemlich viel mit gemacht. Ich habe mal auf dem 19C3 so einen Workshop gemacht, auch Advanced Exploitation, TCP-IP-Hijacking, mal Upspoofing und so und das ist halt alles, ich konnte diese beiden Welten noch nicht wirklich verbinden, so 8-bit Mikrocontroller und Ethernet habe ich mal gegoogelt und dann war da so Ulrich Radik, Web-Server, das war schon ziemlich cool. Er hat alte 10 Megabit-Netzwerkkarten genommen und hat da einen Atmega32 dran gepflanscht und spricht mit denen halt so ein bisschen PCI oder ISA oder sowas, also jedenfalls so einen parallelen Bus, den man normalerweise auf dem PC kennt. Fand ich alles ziemlich unschick, weil so alte Netzwerkkarten, da muss man immer gucken auf Ebay und überhaupt und das war irgendwie nicht so schön und dann hat mir ein Freund von mir irgendwie so 2006, Anfang 2006, so eine Stange ICs in die Hand gerückt und meinte hier, Google mal. Das waren von Microchip, also nicht von Atmel, sondern von der Konkurrenz. Die haben einen Mikrocontroller- kompatiblen Ethernet-Treiber rausgebracht. ENC28J60 lässt sich super leicht ansprechen mit einer Bus-Hardware namens SPI, die da in dem Atmel auch schon eingebaut ist. So ein 3-Pin-Bus. Super schick, weil hat so 8 KB RAM und cached Pakete zwischen und wenn die alten Pakete nicht abgeholt wurden, dann sagt er auf Ethernet-Layer Bescheid. Hier, nee, ist jetzt nicht gerade. Da kann man auch schon so Sachen machen, wie maximale Größe von Paketen festlegen, weil ich hab in meinem Mikrocontroller 2 oder 4 KB Arbeitsspeicher, da hab ich keinen Platz für so 3 von diesen 1,5 KB Monster-Paketen, die da auf Ethernet-Ebene natürlich zusätzlich sind. Deswegen sag ich dem Chip gleich hier, 640 Byte und mehr ist nicht. Dann hab ich mir halt angeguckt und angeguckt und geguckt und dachte mir so, ach, eigentlich wäre das schon schick. Hab mir dann die Software dazu angeguckt, da hat der Ulrich Radik irgendwie auch einen coolen Stack geschrieben, also einen TCP-IP-Stack. Den fand ich aber eigentlich nicht so schick. Der hat z.B. so Sachen wie TCP-Retransmitz noch nicht gemacht, zumindest die 1. Version. Dann hab ich mir dann weitergeguckt und da gibt's irgendwie MyIP, also UIP geschrieben. Ist von einem schwedischen Menschen, der da in einem Informatik-Institut arbeitet, hat den geschrieben. Adam heißt der, glaub ich. Und der ist ziemlich klein und richtig cool. Und da hab ich dann mal weitergeschraubt und auf Lochras dann Plototypen zusammengestöpselt und rausgekommen ist, dass Etherrape, so nach einem, ja gut, ein Dreivierteljahr Hardware-Design und irgendwie immer wieder neu machen, findet man auch auf lochanster.org. Dann gibt's umrecht so ein Menü, wo man klicken kann. Ist gedacht, also um das einfach mal zu beschreiben, das hängt hier auch über unseren Köpfen, hängt das rum von der Decke. So eine Schaltung ist eine Platine, 8 x 10 cm groß, enthält im Prinzip einen Atmega 644, also den großen, großen, großen Bruder von dem Atmega 8. Und einen Ethernet-Treiber, den ich eben erwähnt hatte, mit einer Ethernet-Buchse und ein bisschen Hardware drumherum. Alles, was noch Platz hatte, so eine serielle Schnittstelle ist da gleich mit drauf. Infrarotsender und Empfänger und RS485 ist vorgesehen.
Was? Infrarotempfänger. Das hat sozusagen von dem Nordlichtprojekt gleich da sein.
Vor allen Dingen, es war halt noch Platz. Dann haben wir halt geguckt und dann habe ich mich mit dem Shorty zusammengetan. Der hatte eine Firma. Dann haben wir uns gedacht, weil immer wieder Leute nach Bausätzen gefragt haben. Aber ich irgendwie das Problem habe, dass ich das halt privat einfach nicht mehr machen konnte. Weil es hat halt so Dimensionen angenommen, auch für die Nordlicht. Da habe ich mal für ein paar Leute Bausätze sortiert und das war total nervig. Und jetzt machen wir das halt über Shortys Firma so in richtig. Und da war eben die Frage, weil so Platinenfertigung ist halt super teuer und wenn man das als Privatmensch macht und so, das skaliert irgendwie so gar nicht. Aber wenn man das halt so macht, dann möchte man auch, dass irgendwie in zwei Jahren die Teile immer noch gibt und da war halt diese Geschichte mit den 10 Megabit-Netzwerkkarten, ging halt einfach nicht.
Rapet das Netz?
Ja, so in der Art. Also man hat wirklich von dem Mikro-Controller aus kompletten Zugriff auf die Hardware, will heißen. Wenn ich da ein Paket über das Netzwerk schicken will, wo lauter 23 drinsteht, dann mach ich das halt. Ob das jetzt irgendwie Sinn macht oder nicht, aber dieser Isar-Netzchip macht wirklich nur die Übersetzung zwischen, ich sage ihm, schicke diese Bites ins Netz raus und dann macht er das. Der macht also nur dieses physikalische Layer und sorgt bei reinkommenden Paketen ein bisschen dafür, dass ich die nicht alle mit dem Mikrocontroller angucken muss.
Ja, aber was ist jetzt Sinn und Zweck der Übung? Also was sollen diese Geräte dann tun? Es geht darum, dass man Dinge über Isar-Netzch steuern kann?
Genau, richtig. Weil es gibt immer so diese eine Seite, das ist dieses Messen, Steuern, Regeln. Ich muss jetzt irgendwie den Feuchtigkeitsgehalt meiner Blumenerde erfassen, weil ich das immer vergesse. Versus ich muss irgendwie gucken, sind da irgendwie meine Fenster offen oder Türen offen oder ich will irgendwie das Licht schalten oder sowas. Und dann das über Netzwerk oder sogar über Internet halt zu machen. Da gab es bisher nur die Möglichkeit, entweder einen PC hinzustellen oder zumindest so einen Embedded-Router mit irgendeinem WRT drauf oder sowas und den dann irgendwie zu modden. Aber das fand ich alles sehr unschick. Das muss alles auch nicht sein, weil da brauche ich keine riesen Routing-Hardware hinstellen, wenn ich nur irgendwie den Blumenwasserstand wissen will. Und da war es ganz cool, gedacht ist das Ganze als Plattform, um damit per Internet oder per Netzwerk gesteuerte Sachen basteln zu können. Weil gerade diese Geschichte mit dem Netzwerk, der 28J60 möchte so ein bisschen Außenbeschaltung haben, und das ist schon nicht mehr so ganz so trivial. Das muss man halt einmal gemacht haben. Aber wenn es halt nicht läuft, dann weiß man nicht, woran es liegt. Und das ist halt ganz cool. Es gibt halt eine fertige Platine. Die gibt es auch für relativ günstig. Da kann man da halt klicken. Wenn man die nicht selber etzen, macht auch da gar keinen Spaß mehr, weil das ist so dicht, dass das so 500 Löcher oder so, die alle durchkontaktiert sind.
Was kostet denn das Teil, wenn das so komplett zusammengebaut wird?
Wir haben das nicht komplett zusammengebaut, weil es soll halt für Bastler sein.
Ich meine jetzt an den Bauteilen. Wenn man alles zusammengebaut hat, was muss man jetzt investieren für so eine Karte?
Das Problem ist, es gibt einzelne Teile, die sind sehr teuer. Es gibt diese Netzwerkdose, die einen eingebauten Übertragern hat, für 6-7 Euro. Es gibt diesen ENC2860, der kostet 6-7 Euro. Und der Mikrocontroller. Das sind auch schon die größten Teile. Dann braucht man die Platine, das sind 12-15 Euro, je nachdem, wo man es fertigen lässt. Und alles in allem, so einen Bausatz, kann man halt anbieten für 59 Euro. Gibt es da jetzt? Da kann man dann halt alles dabei. Mit vorprogrammiert und überhaupt.
Okay.
Das ist also die Idee. Wir wollen das weniger aus irgendwie goldenen Nase-Verdienungsabsicht machen.
Nee, das ist doch nicht so. Ich wollte mal so ein bisschen einschätzen, was man jetzt für sowas machen kann. Das ist ja jetzt so wenig Geld auch nicht. Wo du meintest, man braucht ja nicht unbedingt immer so einen kompletten Router, aber die Dinger kommen ja auch zu ähnlichen Preisen mittlerweile auf den Markt.
Ja, das ist wohl wahr. Da muss man halt sehr genau abwägen, was man jetzt wirklich haben will. Weil bei dem Router muss man halt auch noch eventuell sehr viel Zeit investieren, um da irgendwas dranzuflanschen, dass man jetzt wirklich das Licht steuern kann. Das ist da halt dabei. Also gedacht ist das wirklich als Plattform. Und es gibt auch viele Leute...
Also ihr habt hier ganz viele Anschlüsse mit Flachbandsteckern und so weiter.
Genau, wir haben auch ganz viel Hardware noch da draufgepascht, die man alles nicht wirklich braucht, wenn man nur das Licht ein- und ausschalten muss. Das ist auch nur so gedacht, weil ich meine, wenn man schon eine Platine machen lässt, dann kann man da auch drauf packen, bis der Platz weg ist. Da gibt es auch ein schickes Gehäuse für und alles Mögliche. Aber es gibt auch viele Leute, die einfach nur die Schaltung nehmen, sich das selber aufbauen. Das finde ich auch total cool, wenn das Leute machen, weil das ist eigentlich, so ist es gedacht, dieses Bausatzgedöns ist halt nur so drumherum gekommen, weil halt viele Leute nach gefragt haben. Und ich finde das halt cool. Jemand anders hat diese Software da genommen, und das finde ich unheimlich beeindruckend. Das ist ethersex.de. Der hat gesagt, ja, ich finde die Software cool und ich finde die Hardware cool. Ich möchte aber an der Software selber noch was machen. Und weil das ja GPL ist und irgendwie mit zum Versionskontrollsystem getrackt wird, ich nehme das jetzt und baue das weiter. Und er hat zum Beispiel IPv6-Support eingebaut. Und, da war ich ja völlig buff, als ich das gesehen habe, der hat OpenVPN-Support eingebaut. Auf einem 8-Bit-Mikrokontroller mit 4 KB RAM. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Ja, das ist total cool.
Das ist Sport.
Ja, das ist Wahnsinn. Ich möchte den Menschen auch unbedingt mal treffen, weil das ist total cool. Er sagt halt hier, ich bastel keine Hardware, aber die Schaltung hier, können da und das ist der Source Code. Das ist total cool. Er macht auch echt abgefahrenes Zeug.
Vielleicht noch mal zu den Controller-Architekturen. Du hast ja schon gesagt, aber das ist viel mit dem Atmel AVR. Das ist beliebt. Es gibt auch andere, wie zum Beispiel PIX. Es gibt auch noch andere. Es gibt auch vor allem noch sehr viel Einfachere, was auch in der Künstlerszene und Kleinbastelszene, wo es sozusagen um geringfügige Automation geht, aber eben auch so mobil, klein, was auch immer, sind ja auch diese fertigen Microcontroller-Systeme, die von Firmen angeboten werden, recht populär, die man dann eben in Basic programmiert.
Wobei da ganz häufig aber auch einfach ein AVR drunter steckt, der im Prinzip so einen Basic-Interpreter draufgeflasht hat. Also beispielsweise C-Control von Konrad macht das genauso.
Ja, aber es mag ein guter Einstieg sein. Oder wo es manchmal auch wirklich nicht darauf ankommt, dass man wirklich das letzte Bit, den letzten Mikroprozessor-Zyklus noch steuern kann. Nordlicht ist natürlich schon relativ anspruchsvoll, was jetzt Timing betrifft. Wenn man jetzt wirklich nur Lampe an Lampe ausgeht, braucht man das halt nicht. Und da kann man halt auch einfach ein Basic-Commando setzen mit irgendwie Set 5 auf 1 und fertig ist die Laube. Ich wollte es noch mal erwähnt haben, sehr lange sehr populär im Markt ist ja diese Basic-Stamp-Systeme. Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon schon mal was gehört hast.
Genau, habe ich mal angeguckt. Aber da kriegt man halt so eine Plastik-Gummi-Welt, wo man aber nicht wirklich was mit tun kann. Also das war so mein Eindruck.
Das sind ja auch in der Regel geschlossene Systeme. Was weniger geschlossen ist, wohl auch recht populär, ist Arduino.
Genau, das ist ein AVR, eine Art Mega 8 in der Regel. Also Arduino, um das mal kurz zu erklären, ist auch für Künstler und Experimentatoren gedachtes Zeug. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo das herkommt. Ich hab das jetzt auch im letzten Monat erst erfahren, dass es sowas gibt, weil der Joel damit mal rumgespielt hat. Das ist auch im Prinzip eine fertige Platine, fertig bestückt, mit einem Atmel, Atmega 8 in der Regel drauf. Und entweder einer seriölen Klinikstelle zum Programmieren oder USB direkt, wo dann auch so eine USB-nach-seriell-Klinikstelle direkt da drauf ist. Das Coole an dem Arduino-Projekt, also die Hardware ist im Prinzip nichts wirklich Aufwendiges, ist einfach so ein Atmel mit ein bisschen Hühnerfutter drumherum und ganz viel Pins, wo man irgendwie noch so ein Experimentier-Board draufstecken kann und seine eigenen Sachen drauf löten kann. Aber das ganz coole an dem Arduino-Projekt ist, dass die ganz viel Dokumentation haben. Und das ist auch in den letzten zwei Monaten glaube ich sehr, sehr gehypt. Dass auch immer mehr Dokumentation entstanden ist. Und da gibt es dann halt Tutorials, die die Leute da ranführen. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann machen die auch direkt ein C-Code auf der Hardware. Also nicht irgendwie über so ein Basic-Abstraktions-Layer. Also das ist schon dann direkt, aber halt sehr gut dokumentiert. Das finde ich unheimlich toll.
Ja, ich hatte ja neulich den Brie-Petis. Auch bei Chaosradio, der auch mit diesem Arduino arbeitet. Und bei Make Magazine wurde es dann natürlich auch entsprechend gefeatured. Das hat dann auch so einigen Impact. Der Podcast wurde dann auch mal erwähnt. Da wurde mir immer wieder klar, was Web-Impact alles so sein kann. Ja, wie auch immer. Aber auch solche Systeme sind interessant und das Arduino mag vielleicht ein guter Zwischenweg zu sein, weil man dann im Prinzip schon so eine fertige Admin-Plattform bekommt, wo man sich dann auch mit der eigentlichen Kern-Hardware gar nicht mehr rumschlagen muss.
Das war für mich am Anfang ein riesen Problem, weil ich hatte halt nur so ein IC und so ein Steckbrett und irgendwie ein bisschen 5-Woll-Spannung und so ein Parallelport-Programmierkabel mit im Prinzip nur einen Parallelport-Stecker und drei Widerständen und ich musste gleichzeitig Software und Hardware zum Laufen bringen. Das ist eine unheimlich steile Lernkurve. Das hat mich damals ein bisschen genervt. Ich hatte aber dieses Feature, dass mein Vater sowas auch macht seit 25 Jahren und er auch Platinen ätzen kann und so was. Das war halt unheimlich toll. Das ist auch toll für die Vater-Sohn-Beziehung, wenn man dann am Samstagabend zusammen sitzt und auf einmal blinkt die LED so, wie sie soll. Das ist schon sehr, sehr cool. Aber Arduino ist eine tolle Sache zum Einsteigen, vor allen Dingen auch, weil es da sehr viel Dokumentation für Anfänger gibt.
Und die auch das unter Creative Commons-Lizenz, das Referenzdesign haben. Jetzt sehe ich hier gerade die neuen Versionen davon, verwenden auch natürlich Atmel, wie du schon sagtest, ATmega 168. Die alten benutzen ATmega 8. Vielleicht kannst du noch mal kurz einen Überblick geben, was diese AVR-Plattform eigentlich so alles umfasst. Also in was für unterschiedlichen Gruppen und Größenordnungen muss man das jetzt betrachten?
Also es gibt eigentlich, es gibt von dieser AVR-Architektur wie gesagt 8-Bit, das heißt alle Register sind 8-Bit breit und der schaufelt im Prinzip immer byteweise durch die Gegend. Da gibt es im Prinzip ATMEGA und ATTINY. Das sind so die zwei großen Sachen. ATTINY sind diese so ganz kleine Dinger, da teilweise haben die auch nur 4 oder 8 Pins, statt irgendwie 28 und haben sehr viel weniger Speicher. Aber zum Beispiel für so eine, da gibt es auch einen, der ist speziell ausgelegt für Fernbedienungszeugs, da sind also in so normalen handelsüblichen Consumer-Fernbedienungen für Fernseher ist er dann drin. Der ist halt nur dafür ausgelegt und der hat im Prinzip dann auch nur die Hardware, die dafür nötig ist. Der hat zum Beispiel keine serielle Schnittstelle und so.
Das sind dann die Dinger, wo man dann auch einen Plastiktropfen drauf macht und...
Genau, zum Beispiel, den gibt es halt glaube ich auch als Plastiktropfen. Aber in der Regel gibt es dann diese auch in so ganz kleinen SMD-Gehäusen. Also SMD ist im Gegensatz zu bedratet, wie man das früher kannte, gibt es halt jetzt neuerdings SMD, das ist Surface Mounted Device. Sehr viel cooler, weil man kann das mit Automaten bestücken. Sieht auch richtig schick aus, wenn diese Automaten dann so...
Kann man aber nicht mehr so gut von Hand löten.
Genau, kann man nicht mehr so gut von Hand löten, schreckt auch eher ab. Also gerade für Lötanfänger ist das ein Riesenproblem. Und es gibt auch nicht so viele Sachen, zum Beispiel Ethernet-Chips, die es in Nicht-SMD-Gehäusen gibt, gibt es nur den N28J60. Das war das ganz Neue. Und der ist unheimlich gehypt genau deswegen. Weil es eine riesige Hobby-Bastler-Community gibt, die einfach keinen Bock hat, SMD zu löten. Weil diesen RTL 8019 Realtek 10-Migabit-Chip-Satz von den alten PCI-Netzwerkkarten, den gibt es auch. Aber der ist viel teurer. Und das ist irgendwie so ein 80-Pin-SMD-Gehäuse mit einem halben Millimeter Abstand zwischen den Pins. Das will man nicht mehr so löten als Anfänger. Also es gibt Adtiny und AdMega. AdMega ist diese größere Geschichte. Eine der kleineren Sachen ist AdMega 8, ist schon einer der kleineren. Genau, das ist der, der im Fnordlicht ist, der in dem Arduino verwendet wird. Sie haben dann irgendwann den...
Den kleinen Arduino, also den neuen, oder jetzt einen anderen?
Genau, richtig, aber der 168, da wollte ich gerade drauf hinaus. Irgendwann sind sie hergegangen und haben dann mal das Innenleben nochmal ein Redesign gemacht und ein bisschen cooleres Zeug eingebaut. Beispielsweise für die Timer, da gab es da nicht nur einen Register, wo man hinschreiben sollte, bei welchem Zählerstand man Interact kriegt, sondern gab es dann für jeden dieser drei Timer zwei Stück. Das ist dann der AdMega 88, ist quasi gleiches Innenleben, nur moderner, viel cooler. Und den gibt es dann in drei Ausführungen, nämlich mit 8 Kilobyte, so wie der AdMega 8 auch, das ist der 88, mit 4 Kilobyte, der dann nochmal ein Euro günstiger ist, mit der AdMega 48, und mit 16 Kilobyte Flash. Das ist dann der AdMega 168. Und das ist genau der Grund, warum sie ihn da drauf gepackt haben.
Okay, also es ist mehr ein 16-8 sozusagen. Also es steht immer der AdMega 8 drin, und dann ist da noch eine 4 oder eine 8 oder eine 16 davor.
Ja, aber das Coole ist, das Ding ist pin-kompatibel, das heißt, man kann die alte Hardware verwenden und steckt einfach nur den neuen Prozessor da rein.
Okay, aber ist da nicht mehr Software-kompatibel?
Nicht ganz, nein. Man muss also neu compilen, weil vor allen Dingen auch sind mehr Interrupts dazu gekommen. Da hat jetzt fast 30 statt nur 20.
Ah, das heißt also diese Interrupt-Geschichte spielt schon eine große Rolle da an der Weiterentwicklung. So, und das ist aber jetzt im Wesentlichen das.
Das sind so diese AdMega 8, 4888, Es gibt da noch eine ganze andere Latte, das sind so 100 oder 120 Devices, die es da gibt, die sich im Prinzip aber nur unterscheiden. Die haben alle die gleiche CPU, das sind alles die gleichen Obcodes, die CPU versteht die gleiche Sprache. Wo drin sie sich unterscheiden, ist Größe des Flash, Größe des RAM, Größe des EEPROM und angeschlossene Hardware, die es da gibt. Also da haben einige dann zwei Serien-Schnittstellen oder zweimal I2C oder sowas, oder andere Gehäuseformen mit mehr Pins, mit weniger Pins, aber im Prinzip ist das alles eine große Familie. Die sind, bis auf die Außenbeschaltung und den Speicher, nicht großartig unterschiedlich.
Letztendlich muss man sich eigentlich nur für das entscheiden, was man jetzt wirklich braucht, also was man an Schnittstellen braucht, an Pins und Interrupts und so weiter braucht. Die sind dann aber auch unterschiedlich schnell, oder?
Ja, die Geschwindigkeit ist auch noch so eine Geschichte. Diese ersten Revisionen von der Art Megaserie, die konnten immer so bis 16 MHz. Bei der neuen Revision, das ist der AVR Core 5, also die CPU-Revision 5, die können bis 20 MHz. Aber das ist dann auch absolute Obergrenze. Über 20 MHz gibt es in dieser Serie, soweit ich weiß, keinen. Da ist halt dann schon Flaschenhals. Und so ein bisschen unschön ist, dass der Atmel immer so wenig RAM draufpackt. Also der Atmega 8 hat einen Kilobyte RAM, der Atmega 32 hat schon zwei Kilobyte RAM und diese ganzen neueren. Also zum Beispiel Atmega 644 ist der Nachfolger vom Atmega 32. Das ist der, der auf dem Etherwrap drauf ist. Der hat dann schon vier Kilobyte, aber das war's. Mehr ist da nicht. Warum? Gute Frage, weiß ich nicht.
Wer braucht schon mehr als vier Kilobyte?
Also echtes IP zu sprechen ist mit zwei Kilobyte auch möglich, aber ziemlich, ziemlich well.
Also das finde ich ja schon erstaunlich. Ja, vielleicht so zum Abschluss, wo wir vorhin schon so schön bei Infrarot waren.
Genau, richtig.
Du bist mir ja auf dem letzten Kongress über den Weg gelaufen und hast kurz erwähnt, dass du da noch ein neues Projekt hast. Was, ja, vielleicht erläuterst du es einfach mal selbst.
Es gibt ja das TV-B-Gorn. Das ist im Prinzip ein kleines Plasteteil, was man sich so an schlüsselbunt machen kann. Und was, wenn man auf den Knopf drückt, der da drauf ist, einfach nur alle Infrarot-Ausschaltcodes für TVs abspielt, die es so kennt.
Das war ja wieder ein großer Renner auch auf dem Kongress. Der Mitch Altman, der das entwickelt hat, der war ja auch da zum wiederholten Male, auch beim Camp schon, hatte da lustige Workshops, auch mit seinen Brain-Machines. Verwendet ihr da eigentlich auch die gleiche Technik?
Ja, genau. Der Mitch hat also ursprünglich damit angefangen, weil es gab, das ist jetzt so eine Urban Legend, ich hab da keine Quelle für, ich hab das nur mal gehört, weil es von einer Firma, die so spezielle Mikrocontroller für Fernbedienungen herstellt, von denen gab es so ganz günstig so ein Devil Board, wo man halt so ein Mikrocontroller mit so ein bisschen Infrarot mal drauf hatte. Und unter anderem gab es dazu eine riesige Library von fertig vorkonfektionierten Infrarotcodes quasi. Mitch hat das einfach zusammengeklickt und alle anderen außer die Ausschaltcodes rausgeworfen und das im Prinzip in China fertigen lassen. So, das ist jetzt erst mal das TV Be Gone.
Das heißt, dieses Gerät für die Leute, die das noch nicht kennengelernt haben, muss man noch mal beschreiben. Man drückt einmal auf eine Taste und daraufhin ist dieses Gerät 30 Sekunden oder so 60 Sekunden lang dabei, einen Fernsehausschalt-Infrarotcode nach dem anderen auszuspucken mit den Ergebnissen. Da gab es ja auch auf dem letzten Konzert einen schönen Inzident dazu, dass eigentlich alle Fernseher, die einen eingeschalteten Infrarot-Sendor haben, und das sind in der Regel halt alle, weil es einfach kein Fernseher hat, eine Taste, dass man das ausschalten kann. Man müsste es also wirklich schon mit Gaffa-Tape abkleben und das macht natürlich keiner, insbesondere nicht in großen Läden, wo Fernseher verkauft werden. Und dann gehen sie halt einfach alle aus. Und das ist natürlich eine tolle Sache, weil wenn man jetzt, wir kennen das alle, man ist im Flughafen, irgendwo so eine komische Kneipe, man muss sich echt mal erholen von dem ganzen Stress und dann ist da so ein plärriger, lärmender Fernseher, der irgendeinen sinnlosen Dumpfbacken-Programm die ganze Zeit nervtöten.
Klingelt schon Werbung.
Alles Mögliche. Und man merkt aber auch, keiner schaut zu. Und dann drückt man einfach mal eine Taste und auf einmal ist Ruhe. Und in der Regel ist es ja dann auch so, kein Sturz, dass das Ding aus ist. Und das Personal hat dann auch irgendwie auch andere Sachen zu tun, als permanenten Fernseher anzuschalten.
Ich hab die Erfahrung gemacht, dass das Personal auch das einfach nicht merkt, dass der aus ist. Naja, also jedenfalls, wir waren, ich war mit meinem Bruder zusammen auf dem Kongress und wir fuhren dann so im Media-Markt, weil irgendwie USB-Hub kaufen oder was waren wir da, ich weiß nicht, fuhren wir dann so eine Rolltreppe hoch und man muss wissen, dass...
Der tolle neue Media-Markt, ein tollen neuen Alexa.
Genau, da ist direkt neben dem BCC so ein Monster-Mörder-Hyper, 300 Geschäfte und mehr Einkaufszentrum mit Burger King, McDonald's und so weiter.
Das Alexa.
Und alles aufgemacht und da ist auch so ein 4000 Quadratmeter Media-Markt über vier Etagen drin. Wir fuhren da halt so hoch, die Rolltreppe, und an der Rolltreppe dran waren halt so 25 TFTs an die Wand geschraubt, wo man so dran langfuhr. Und dann kam man dann so hoch und guckte so auf eine Monster-50-Fernseher-Wand. Daneben guckte man dann weiter und sah diesen 3,80 Meter-Euro-Fernseher. Und das war, ich hab meinen Bruder angeguckt, er hat mich angeguckt und haben beide das Gleiche gedacht. So jetzt wär's echt mal Schicks und Ding zu haben. Das Problem war, es war dann schon 9 Uhr abends und der Media-Markt macht um 22 Uhr zu. Wir wollten natürlich direkt loslegen. Aber Mitch war nicht auftreibbar, weil er hatte irgendwie einen verschobenen Tagesrhythmus und war ganz seltsam und hat immer nur gesagt, wenn Leute ihn fragten, wann er wieder da ist, dann hat er immer nur gesagt, ja, wenn ich wieder wach bin. Und er war nicht auftreibbar. Und dann ist uns irgendwann aufgefallen, ja, ich habe doch hier noch diese alten Isarate-Bausätze und diesen Mikrocontroller und diese Infrarot-LEDs. Und dann hab ich halt gestöpselt und eine Stunde später war dann leider der Media-Markt schon zu, aber die Hardware fertig. Und am nächsten Mittag lief das dann. Ich hatte mir dann angeguckt, weil der Mitch hat nicht nur dieses Plastik-Hina-Fertig-Teil gebaut, sondern der hat auch zusammen mit der Lady Ada hat er Bausätze davon gemacht und hat quasi einen Open Source TV-Begonnen rausgebracht, wo er auch ganz viele Fernsehcodes schon veröffentlicht hat, also so als Abfolgen von eingeschaltet, ausgeschaltet, mit Timing dazwischen. Und hat er schon freigegeben im Netz und ich hatte mir das halt angeguckt, hab die Hardware angeguckt, fand die nicht so toll, hab die neu gemacht, hab mir die Software angeguckt, fand die auch nicht so toll, hab die auch neu gemacht und hab das dann wieder auf meine Seite gestellt, als Projekt namens UNZAP. Und da war dann auch schon ganz viel Interesse auf dem Kongress selber da, weil der Mitch hat den Straight-Forward-Weg genommen und diese Codes halt auch im Mikrocontroller abgelegt, der benutzt übrigens diese Offensource-Bausätze, benutzen auch einen ATT-Tiny 18, so ein kleiner, also quasi ATMEGA8 in ganz klein, ganz kleines Gehäuse. Und der hat die Codes da alle abgelegt als Schalte 500 Mikrosekunden die LED ein, dann warte 1,5 Millisekunden, dann schalte sie wieder an. Das Problem ist, wenn man sehr viele sehr gleichartige Codes hat, was so der Fall war, dann werden diese Codes sehr schnell sehr groß, weil man diese Timing-Dinger immer als 16-Bit-Wert, also zwei Byte, ablegen muss. Und dann hat man da so 30 von diesen Dingern, die jeweils zwei Byte groß sind und davon 100 Stück. Und dann ist man schon sehr schnell am Ende. Da habe ich mir halt gedacht, das mache ich ordentlich und neu und überhaupt. Und habe dann schon auf dem Kongress die erste Platine geroutet und habe dann auch schon fast, Gott sei Dank habe ich es nicht gemacht, aber ich wollte da direkt schon Prototypen davon bestellen und überhaupt. Und dann habe ich das nicht gemacht. Dann habe ich dann eine Woche später Prototypen bestellt. Und da war im Prinzip nur so vier Infrarot-LEDs mit so einem neuen Volt-Block-Anschluss-Clips auf dreimal fünf Zentimeter Platinengröße. Dann habe ich mir überlegt, na eigentlich kannst du da irgendwie mehr draus machen. Aber weil der Atmel, der langweilt sich ja, wenn er nur...
Mehr was?
Also mehr Funktionalität. Weil der Atmel langweilt sich ja, wenn er da einfach nur wartet, dass der Fernbedienungscode dazu Ende ist. Und dann habe ich halt nachgedacht und dann war klar, ja guck mal, wir können doch eigentlich auch, weil wenn man irgendwie so einen Code noch nicht hat, ist das blöd, weil da geht der Fernseher nicht aus. Aber bei den großen Elektronik-Discounten hängt die Fernbedienung ja immer da dran am Gerät, damit man das testen kann. Es wäre halt cool, wenn man da sagen könnte, okay, dann lernen wir jetzt grad fix, und dann hält man die Fernbedienung da dran und hat man den Code und kann ihn nachher angucken. Naja, aber eigentlich wäre es irgendwie cool, wenn man noch, also habe ich dann so einen TSOP, wie eben schon erwähnt, da draufgebaut. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, eigentlich wäre es auch cool, wenn man so die Trägerfrequenz erkennen könnte und habe dann noch so eine Infrarot-Diode drauf, also eine Infrarot-Erfänger-Diode draufgebaut. Da habe ich mir überlegt, eigentlich wäre es noch cool, wenn man da... Ja, Infrarot funktioniert so. Infrarotlicht wird auch ausgestrahlt, z.B. von Menschen, also Wärmestrahlung oder von Energiesparlampen oder von der Sonne beispielsweise. Und der Fernseher muss unterscheiden können zwischen dem Streulicht und dem wirklichen Nutzsignal. Also macht er das, was die Baustellen auf der Autobahn auch machen, sie blinken. Und in dem Fall wird eine Infrarot-LED mit etwa so 30 bis 40 Kilohertz ein- und ausgeschaltet. Oder eben nicht. Also man sieht diese gepulste LED, dann sieht man sie eine Zeit lang nicht, dann sieht man sie wieder. Und das ist im Prinzip der Infrarot-Code. Die sind alle gleich. Alle nach diesem Schema. Manche etwas mehr, manche etwas weniger, manche sind länger. Und dann kann man halt zum Beispiel sagen, man codiert eine 1 als ein kurzer Infrarot-LED-Gepulst eingeschaltet und dann 500 Millisekunden ausgeschaltet und dann Infrarot-LED eingeschaltet und eine Millisekunde ausgeschaltet, ist dann eine 0 oder so. Das ist so ein gängiger Infrarot-Code. Da gibt's auch im Netz jede Menge Zeug dazu. Wir tun das dann in den Link nochmal da rein.
Dauert lange, aber kann dann zumindest deutlich unterschieden werden.
Genau, kann auch deutlich unterschieden werden. Und da gibt's halt diese zwei Komponenten. Einmal diese Trägerfrequenz, weil die Empfänger, die haben einen Filter drin für genau diese Trägerfrequenz. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel der Empfänger damit rechnet, mit 38 Kilohertz gepulste LEDs zu beobachten, dann beobachtet der bitte auch nur die. Andernfalls ist der halt in der Reichweite sehr eingeschränkt. Und deswegen möchte man schon wissen, ob das jetzt 32 Kilohertz oder 40 sind.
Das heißt, die Fernbedienungen unterscheiden sich auch nicht nur in den Codes selber, sondern auch in der Frequenz. Und wie viele unterschiedliche Frequenzen gibt es da so?
Also die gängigen sind so, hab ich mir sagen lassen, hab ich im Netz gelesen, 20 bis 60 Kilohertz. Das sind die gängigen. Ich hab selber gesehen von irgendwie 28 bis 42 Kilohertz. Das hab ich ausprobiert mit so einer Universal-Fernbedienung. Es gibt aber auch so Ausreißer wie Bang & Olufsen zum Beispiel, die werden in den Podcasts immer wieder erwähnt. Das ist fürchterlich. Ja, jetzt wissen wir warum. Die haben eine Trägerfrequenz von 450 Kilohertz. Und dann gibt es noch einen ganz uralten Code, der benutzt gar keine Trägerfrequenz.
Ok, also dein Projekt ist jetzt das Ding so zu machen, dass einerseits alle Tabellen drin sind, die man haben will. Hab ich dich richtig verstanden? Du hast ja jetzt noch einen Ansatz gefunden, wie du mehr Codes untergrößt oder was?
Ja, weil ich hab mir halt die Codes angeguckt, die Mitch da eingebaut hat. Und das sind ganz viele, die einfach die gleiche Modulationsart, also gleiche Frequenz für die LED zum Pulsen und gleiche Codierung, der 0 und 1 hat, aber einfach nur in den Daten, die sie wirklich senden, unterscheiden. Und da kann ich natürlich dann implementieren, ich halte einmal dieses Protokoll und speichere da nur diese 2 Weitdaten.
Ok, also du fasst sie sozusagen nach Typ zusammen und sparst dadurch Platz. Aber andererseits, in dem Moment, wo irgendwas nicht da ist, kann man auch sagen, hier Lern mal.
Genau, das ist die Idee. Und dann hab ich mir überlegt, ach guck mal, da ist irgendwie noch so ein 3 Quadrat Millimeter Platz. Gucken wir nochmal, was können wir da noch draufsetzen? Dann war halt die Idee so, ja, wir haben doch hier schon auf dem Etherwraith verbaut diesen 2 Megabyte Data-Flash von Atmel auch, der kostet irgendwie einen Euro oder sowas. 2 Megabyte kann ich Daten rein und Daten raus tun. Das ist doch super, da kann man noch mehr Zeug reintun, weil auch so ein Atmega 168 mit 16 Kilobyte ist halt sehr begrenzt, aber 2 Megabyte ist erstmal, gib ihm. Und dann hab ich mir überlegt, ach guck mal, da ist immer noch Platz. Und dann kam ein Freund von mir an und meinte so, ach guck mal, ich hab hier gesehen ein Atmel mit so einem Software-USB-Stack. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, so eine generische Sende-Empfangs-Ding für mit USB und überhaupt wäre cool. Und jetzt ist da USB auch noch mit drauf. Um zum Beispiel Codes auszulesen, die man gelernt hat oder neue Codes reinzutun, ohne ihn neu zu programmieren und überhaupt. Und da gibt es auch noch eine ganze... Das hab ich mit Mitch schon besprochen.
Hey, nach dem Klingeltonenmarkt ein vollkommen neues.
Ja, aber das hab ich mit Mitch schon besprochen. Wir werden zusammen eine Datenbank machen, wo wir diese Infrarotcodes mal sammeln, die auch dann projektübergreifend irgendwie ist, weil es ist blöd, wenn man das nur so ein Projekt beschränkt. Und was auch noch ganz cool ist, das hab ich im Nachhinein, aber erst, das hat mich auch jetzt dieses Jahr als interessiert. Das ist immer so, irgendwann kommt das und macht das jemand, interessiert mich nicht, und irgendwann krieg ich so ein, kippt so ein Fleck um und dann interessiert mich das. Und jetzt hab ich gesehen, der Major Malfunction aus London, der hat letztes und vorletztes Jahr auf dem Kongress jeweils einen Vortrag gehalten über Oldschool-Infrared-Hacking. Und der ist auch, das ist eine supergeile Idee, der geht quasi hin, guckt sich an, wie so eine Fernbedienung ihre Codes moduliert, guckt sich an, welche Codes es auf der Fernbedienung gibt, und guckt, wie der Fernseher auf Codes reagiert, die es nicht als Knopf gibt. Und da hat er in Hotels zum Beispiel ganz viel interessantes Zeug gefunden, weil zum Beispiel das Hilton Hotel oder alle möglichen anderen auch, da hat er auch, kann man sich mal angucken, super interessant, da ist er halt ins Hotel gegangen und hat dieses, normalerweise werden Hotels über die Fernseher, können die noch mal ganz viele andere Funktionen machen, beispielsweise die Minibar-Abrechnung oder Surfen oder sowas. Und er hat sich halt die Hotel-Fernbedienung genommen und hat geguckt, wie der Fernseher auf Codes reagiert, die auf der Hotel-Fernbedienung nicht drauf waren. Er hat da so Sachen gefunden wie eine Taste wie Minibar-Abrechnung gemacht, setz mal den Zeller zurück, klick und so Sachen. Also super spannende Sache. Und das will ich halt auch machen. Dadurch, dass das Teil USB hat, kann ich mich halt auch in die Vorlesung setzen, raten, wie die Beamer-Fernbedienung von dem Prof gerade ihre Codes sendet und kann halt auch mal vielleicht mitlesen, kann mal gucken, ob ich das empfange. Und dann während der Vorlesung einfach mal den Blutforcer laufen lassen und mal gucken, was da der Beamer für lustige Sachen von sich gibt. Und dafür ist das gedacht.
Also es gibt auch noch eine ganze Menge. Also die Vorträge, auf die du dich bezogen hast, waren auf dem 21. und 22C3. Da hat er dann nochmal ein Update gemacht, ein Jahr später. Die kann man sich auf jeden Fall nochmal anschauen. Die sind auch bei Chaosradio verfügbar. Zumindest der eine, der andere hoffentlich auch bald, weil ich jetzt gerade dabei bin, auch Chaosradio ccc.de, noch mehr altes Zeug überzuhelfen. Campvideos sind gerade dazu gekommen. 24C3. Ja. Super, sag ich mal. Ich denke, wir haben jetzt eigentlich alles angesprochen, was wir mal so besprechen wollten.
Also noch einen Nachtrag zu den ganzen Sachen. Also guckt auf die Webseite, da gibt's eine ganze Menge Infos. lochraster.org. Wenn nicht, es gibt auf jeden Fall für jedes Projekt gibt es eine Mailing-Liste, wo man einfach auch mal nachfragen kann. Und auch für dieses Ansepp habe ich halt auch Platinen gemacht, die halt schön schick klein sind und sowas. Und die gibt's aber alles noch nicht. Und wenn es euch interessiert, gibt's eine Mailing-Liste.
Baut ihr die dann auch in so einen kleinen Schlüsselanhänger mit ein?
Ne, aber die sind dreimal 5, also 33, immer 55 Millimeter. Und die sollen eigentlich in so Tick-Tack-Schechelchen reinpassen. Ja, Schlüsselanhänger wäre cool. Das stimmt, man muss noch ein Gehäuse raussuchen. Was der Mitch auch erzählt hat, dass er teilweise ganz, ganz komisch angeguckt wurde, wenn er mit so einer Platine, wo man offen die Teile sieht, in so einem Supermarkt herumgerannt ist. Er meinte, er hat dann einfach einen schwarzen Kasten genommen und dann rannte er darum, da haben die Leute ihn noch komischer angeguckt. Und dann hat er einen Aufkleber draufgemacht, der quasi aussieht, als wäre das ein Handy, so mit Tasten und Bildschirm, und hat es immer ins Ohr gehalten. Da hat niemand geguckt. Also es gibt da noch Optimierungsbedarf.
Ja, alte Nokia-Gehäuse, da kann man sich das dann reinbauen.
Genau, es ist auch klein genug. Und es ist aber auch so gedacht, dass man dann auch... Also die Hardware ist in der Lage, auch so ein 12 Volt Bleigel-Akku aus dem Rucksack zu benutzen als Quelle. Und dann kann man da noch mehr LEDs dranhängen.
Dann kann man so rumlaufen wie Ghostbusters oder irgendwie alle Fernseher am Alexanderplatz in Berlin und weltweit ausmachen.
Ich will noch mal so eine Base-Cap haben, wo halt rundherum so Infrarot-LEDs unauffällig angebracht sind und sowas.
Oh weia. Auf jeden Fall aufpassen, kann ich dazu nur sagen. Es gab da auf dem Kongress auch so ein Incident, die Mitarbeiter beim Media-Markt waren am Schluss nicht ganz so amused.
Ja, das war aber auch teilweise, weil die Leute mit Ubuntu-CDs hingegangen sind und das Vista von den Notebooks gebügelt haben und so.
Oh Gott, das haben wir jetzt nicht erzählt. Egal. Auf jeden Fall, man muss schon achten, geht es darum, einem jetzt ein bisschen Ruhe zu bescheren, was ich angemessen finde. Oder geht es darum, jetzt nur irgendwelche Leute bei der Ausübung ihres Jobs zu nerven? Ich meine, so ein Fernsehladen, verkaufe nun mal Fernseher und dass sie jetzt nicht darüber nachdenken. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass demnächst die Dinger dann auch alle mal wieder abgeklebt sind, aber das Problem ist, wie schalten die dann ihre Fernseher abends aus?
Genau, es ist auch jetzt eher sekundär dazu gedacht. Es ist halt auch cool, weil es ist im Prinzip genau die Hardware, die der Major Now Function in seinen Vorträgen damals irgendwie noch kommerziell gekauft hat. Weil es ist halt so ein generisches Infrarot-Senderempfang mit ungefähr allem. Und das soll auch LERC-kompatibel sein, das ist dieses Linux-Infrared-Control-Projekt, wo ganz schön, die haben auch eine riesen Datenbank von Infrarot-Fernbedienungscodes und so was. Und das soll auch kompatibel sein dazu nachher, dass man das einfach so in Schick hat mit USB und zum Selberlöten und auch für Lötanfänger lötbar.
Also kann man auf jeden Fall super was bei lernen, eine Menge Spaß haben, es gibt genug Infrarot-Geräte da draußen und es gibt auch noch eine Menge, die noch gebaut werden sollten, weil Infrarotsteuerung funktioniert einfach mal super als Fernbedienung und sicherlich kann man auch auf so einige Ideen kommen. Ja, lochanstar.org, FT0, deine Website, dort ist alles dokumentiert. Ich kann euch allen nur mal raten, euch auch weiterhin mit Hands-on-Hacking zu beschäftigen. Jetzt haben wir innerhalb kürzester Zeit mehrere Sendungen zu dem Thema gehabt und es wird nicht die letzte sein. Ja, ich sage erstmal Dankeschön, FT0. Und das war es, Chaosradio Express, Nummer 67. Und wie immer zum Schluss der Hinweis, Feedback erwünscht ChaosradioFCC CDE oder schaut in unserer Blog, kommentiert fleißig, wir sind für alles zu haben. Ja, und dann sage ich nochmal Dankeschön und Tschüss an alle. Bis bald, das war's bei Chaosradio Express.